サッブパーパッサアカラナン
クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨーダパナン
エータンブッダナサーサナン
今日はウェーサーカ祭りで
ウェーサーカっていうのは仏教という教えが世に現れたこと
我々はとても大事にお祝いをする日なんですね
仏教が現れたのは 当然お釈迦様がブッダになってからなんですね
当然 シッダールタ王子が生まれたからなんですね
それから仏教が語る完全な苦しみをなくした究極の幸福である涅槃という境地
それはお釈迦様が最初に
まあ最初でもないんだけどもね
涅槃に入られたというね
そういう必須の出来事で
我々は象徴として仏教が世に現れたこと
ブッダが現れたこと 法が現れたこと
それから聖なるサンガが現れたことを記念してお祝いをする
その日なんですね お釈迦様が教えたことは真理であって
過去においても 現在においても
将来においても ブッダが教えた言葉はそうでないという人は現れません
あるいはブッダの教えをちょっと訂正して
もっともっとかっこよく
もっと完璧に 喋られる生命も絶対存在しないのです
だからお釈迦様がオープンチャレンジで
これはありえないんだと
いるならば出てきてください
ちゃんと批判してみてくださいとオープンチャレンジで置いておるのです
ということは 将来現れるだろうと思う
超知識人で超エリートの方々にも
もの超科学者たちにもチャレンジはオープンです
ブッダの教えに何か間違いあるならば示してくれというチャレンジはするあるのです
いまだに誰にもできなかったのです
これからもできないのです
なぜならば 世界は発展するように見えるんだけど
同じところでぐるぐる回っているだけなんです
生命っていうのは 我々今は携帯依存症になったからといって
何か人格的に優れたわけじゃないんです
同じところで回転しているんですよ
携帯なかった時は何かの妄想して
何か考えて 誰かと喋って無駄な時間使っていたんですね
今はよりたくさん無駄な時間を使っているんですね
携帯でいろんなことを見ながら
だからそれでもって人間が発展したわけじゃないんです
しかし コミュニケーションが発達すると
それを正しく使うこともできます
お互いに理解し合って
民族差別をなくして 国差別をなくして
国境を壊し合って すべて人間一つになることも可能ですけど
こんなくだら人間がそれをやらないんです
噂ばっかり流したりして
自分言いたい放題のくだらないことを言い出したりして
なおさら人間の間で分かれるように
お互いに喧嘩するようなことに使っているんですよ
だから人間は発展していないんです
で 携帯の次 何が現れるかわかりませんけども
いろいろガラクタ現れるでしょうね
私はガラクタと言うんだからね
それ何かに依存する 何かに依存する
だから何かに依存して真理を忘れることはずっと変わってないんです
だから宇宙のブラックホールの写真撮ったとかね
ブラックホールの写真撮れないんだけど
まあただ計算して計算して撮れたと言うんだけどね
それで黒い輪っか描けばもうブラックホールですけどね
で まあそれなりにデータをね
ブラックホールの周りの信号をね
まあなんとか受け取って
あの まあそれってありえないことだから
まあ科学者が威張ってるんですね
大体素粒子がそこから出てこないんですね
それでも何か出てくるものを取って
それで計算してシミュレーションして写真撮ったということになっていてね
それでみんな不思議 不思議だね
これで喜んじゃって まあ 1週間で忘れるんで
皆さんも忘れてるでしょ
ブラックホールの写真撮ったってことで大騒ぎになったっていうことは
もうもうそんなにもう 2 3ヶ月も経ってないんだけどね
で そういうことでも何かをもう何かを発見しまった
あれ発明しまったとかね
大騒ぎして それからまた元にグーッと戻っちゃうという世界の人間なんですよ
だから生きるとは何やと
この質問に未だに誰にも答えることはできません
いくら科学の方向でいくら研究しても
みんな命はどこから来たのかと調べるだけで調べても見つかりっこないでしょうに
これっていうのは遠い遠い遠い昔に起きた起きた出来事だから
まあそれ 命の多次元的な
いろんな次元の命があるっていうことは証明しない限り
このアミノ酸でできている
DNA でできている この形が命やと思っちゃうと
地球上でしか生命がないや
例えば火星で生命がいたとしても
DNA でできてないでしょうに
できるはずがないでしょうに
そこで仏教ではね お釈迦様は宇宙のいろんなところにある生命にも語りましたと
遠い昔からもう仏教ではだいたい廊下だとか言っています
アスワルダでね  アスワルダ
で  8万4000ぐらいの宇宙空間でね
同じ人間と同じの次元の生命がいて
そちらにもブッダの話は通じるんだよと
ブッダに語られてければ
そういう生命にも語れますよ
だからそういう考えちゃうと
この一つの星団の中でも
我々の星団の中でも かなり遠く遠くまで調べなくちゃあかんでしょ
太陽があるんだからといって惑星がある保証はないし
惑星があるからといって地球と同じ環境がある保証はないですよ
それでもあまり無限にあるんだから
必ず生命はいるんだという
我々は 2600年前からもう一般的に言ってるんですよ
仏教徒たちには この 8万4000 の宇宙生命っていうのは一般的なフレーズなんです
ですから このブッダの教えっていうのはすごいんです
で お釈迦様はこのどんな人も考えているのは
どうやって幸福に生きられるのかって
このくだらない目的なんですよ
人間考える 幸福によく食って
家族が仲良く ぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃと楽しく
まあ付き合っている友達もいて
またいっぱいも金があって
それで我輩は満足 で このアホたちが理解しないのは
毎日年を取っていくんですよ
家族が仲良くしたっても
ある僅かな時間だけですよ
家族はバラバラになって出て行くんです
独立するんです それで体が衰えていくと
いくら財産あっても使えないんです
いくらごちそうあっても食べられないんです
体が病気です だからあっけなく惨めに誰でも死ぬんだから
はっきりとあなた方のモットーは目標はくだらないんだと
元の 長持ちする模型を作ったらどうですかと
そこで宗教の人々は ああ
体が死んだっても魂は死なないんだからね
天国で永遠にいるんだと
それにはうちの神様を信仰しなかったらあかんやと
永遠の天国に入場券というか
パスが必要なんですね
おかしいでしょうに そんなことあったら
どんな人間でもそちらに行けなきゃ変でしょうに
なんでどこかのヤクザのドンからね
パス取らなくちゃあかんですかね
だからその方々も勘違いしているのは
この肉体の延長なんですね
だから頭がイカれているのも決まっているんです
それでお釈迦様がこういう我々支配する
管理する そんな恐ろしい生命はありえないんだと
どう見ても私たちは共存で生きているんだよと
助け合って生きているんだよと
この体の中でももう体重 2 3 キロぐらい微生物が住んでいるんですよ
その微生物も一個一個の生命なんですよ
その生命体が元気で健康でいなきゃ
私の健康も潰れます そこで他の生命がいるからこそ
私は生きているんです
生命と関係ないものといえば
我々に取れることはできるのは水と酸素だけ
他全て生命として体に肉体に入れなくちゃいけない
しかし 肉体があっても生きるエネルギーがないんです
心のエネルギー だから心にも栄養が必要です
その心に必要な栄養は他の生命を与えてくれるんです
例えば誰かさんが私の誰にも言ってくれませんだけど
これから言ってください
まああの私の顔見て あ
今日は先生元気そうですね
嘘でも言ってくれると
なんとなく気分良くなるでしょ
栄養が入っちゃったんです
人がなんかやっちゃうとね
まあ料理でも作っておいちゃうと
あ お上手ですね よくごちそうですねとかね
言ってくれれば あの作った人のあの疲れがサッと消えちゃうんです
エネルギーが入るんですよ
だから我々の心もずっと充電しなくちゃいけないんですよ
でないと電気切れちゃって死んじゃうんです
精神的なショックでただちに死にますよ
いくら豊かな環境でいても
その人は精神的にダメージを受けちゃうと力が抜けちゃうと
そのまま落ち込んだまんまで体が肉体が衰退して死ぬんです
食べた食べ物も体に入らないんですよ
明るい心がなかったら
だからみんないつでも一人で食べるよりは
誰か誰かいた方がなんとなく元気でしょ
同じもの 例えばすごいごちそう一人で食べる 4
人でおにぎりを食べる
どちらが栄養になるかというと
まあ4人で食べたおにぎりが栄養になるんです
なぜならば 4人の間で心のつながりがあったんだからなんですね
そういうのは科学的に証明する必要ない
一人一人に立証できるものなんです
だから 科学者みたいに 100億
300億ぐらいお金かけてくだらない金具作って爆破させて研究するでしょう
時々ロケットとか打ち上げるでしょうに
ほんのちょっとの数字の間違いでドカンと爆発するんですよ
どれぐらい金なくなる？あのお金で毎週人々に何か国で助けてあげればいいのに
だから 1円もかからない研究は仏教は教えているんです
それまた真理なんです
だから心に栄養が必要です
肉体には物質がちょっと入れ替えなくちゃいけない
そちらにしたっても 生命を媒介していないと入れません
ほうれん草を食べなくちゃあかん
鉄食ったっても 鉄分が体に入りません
炭を噛んだからといって体に炭素が入りません
ご飯かパンか食べなくちゃいけないでしょ
それは生命なんです 生命とは言えませんだけど
生命の部品なんですね
ですから 我々の唯一幸福な生き方は何ですかね
すべての生命が幸福でありますように
元気でありますように
明るく生活できますように
幸せでありますようにと思うことでしょう
それに神っていうのは恐るべき殺人機が必要ですかね
どんな神でも最後の審判がありますからね
みんな殺しちゃいますよ
そう考えればテロリストの方が甘いんです
そんなたくさん殺せませんだからね
だからこのテロを応援する神を捨てて
真理 科学的な事実を信じなさいと
遠い昔 キリスト教以前にも
最近人殺してる宗教が現れる以前
お釈迦様教えたんです
殺すことは神の定めだと思っていたヒンドゥ教
バラモン教であっても
仏教の影響で戦争しないんです
私はヒンドゥ教は戦争したってもあまり不思議に思わない
なぜならば 聖書にそう書いていますよ
ヒンドゥ教は聖書として見ているマハーバーラタというテキストがある
あれはちょっとした文学の作品ですけど
でもヒンドゥ教にとってはそれは聖書なんですね
それはあの ヒストリーフォー war なんですよ
戦いの物語なんです 本当の戦争の物語なんです
だったら我々の精神は戦い
戦い 戦い 殺しまくっちゃえと書いているんだから
じゃあやっちゃいましょうとやってないんです
なぜならば ヒンドゥ教はブッダを捨てましたけど
教えの影響は変えることはできません
彼らも神よりダルマを大事にするんです
ダルマっていうのは真理なんです
ヒンドゥ教の人々もよく口先にダルマ
ダルマ ダルマという言葉を使っているんです
ダルマとは何ですか？と聞いたらよくわからないわけです
はい そういうことで 人類に唯一真理家だったお釈迦様ですので
我々の目の前で幸福になることはできて
この世にあるすべての問題にお釈迦様は答えを出しているんでしょうに
なんで人間がそんなに仏教を嫌いかよくわからないんだけど
お釈迦様がおっしゃった一行
サッベーサッターバーント sukiタッタ
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
何も信仰いらんでしょ
世界中人類がスリーマムればどうなる？それで北朝鮮との関係も解決するでしょ
なんで頭イカれた金正恩さんの言葉聞くんですかね
なんで頭イカれたんだった？何でしたっけ？アメリカの大統領の話聞くんですかね
権力欲があるんだったら頭が病気ですよ
だから私も悪口言ってるように聞こえますけど
私は論理的に心理学的に言うんですね
そこまで権力を握りたいんだったら
あなたは病気です 健康な精神を持っている人は穏やかに生きる
あれがなければ これがなければ
あれが欲しい これが欲しいという病気がないんです
だからアメリカの凶暴な態度で世界に迷惑
プーチンさんの凶暴な態度で世界に迷惑
そういうことで 人類がこの一行
神を信じなさいと言ってないんです
私より他の神を信じたらただで済まんぞという脅しはないんです
自分の自由な意思でやってくださいと
自分で考えてくださいと
自分で考えたら 私が言っていることは正しいとあなた自身でわかるでしょう
人に聞く必要はないでしょう
人やいろんな化け物を信仰する必要はないでしょう
何かくだらない何かお札とか何とかとかで
これで私を守られますよと
守れませんよ 今 最近私は乗る車にはないんだけど
昔はいろんな方々がね
いろいろ運んでくれた
車のダッシュボード前
お守り 交通安全のあれはあるわ
私は言ったんだ ある日
これ 1 万ぐらい貼っておけと
ウインズストリート 神様の力であんたは安全運転できますよ
いくらあんなものを貼っても
運転手さんが落ち着いて混乱しないで
怒りに狂わないで運転しなきゃダメでしょ
丁寧に法則を守って 赤信号で止めて
ですから この自分自身の性格が自分を守る
誰もあなた方を守ってくれませんよ
産んだ母親にも自分を守ることできません
小さい時は守っていますけどね
これはダメ ダメとか言いながら
大きくなったらどうする？だからどこへいても自分が自分を守る世界であるという
それは事実でしょうに
どうやって守るかと 清らかな心
病気のない心 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみのない心があれば守られます
私は怒る場合は人に怒るのです
怒られた人は私の幸せを願う
願うはずがない 嫉妬すると人に嫉妬する
嫉妬を受けた人が この方は長生きできますように
幸福でありますようにと思う
思わないでしょう 例えば高学歴あっても面接しに行ったら
それほど学歴は良くないんだけど
性格見るとすごく落ち着いている
行儀さんは完璧 立つ時
座る時 挨拶する時は心込めてやる
その人を選べますよ 例えばハーバード大学の博士を取ったっても
強盗やる人だったら 痴漢やる人だったら雇う
痴漢ケース 4つあるんだと
でもハーバード大学の博士で
もう英語ペラペラで結構研究論文も書いてるんだよと
雇うそんな人を 大学教授だても何人かクビになったでしょ
こんなに手を出して だから知識が消えたんですかね
教授はクビになります
なぜならば この人の研究知識が消えたはないでしょう
認知症になったと そんなないでしょ
道徳守ってない 心は汚い
だから信頼できない 大学教授であっても
男だったら女性の学生さんたちがね
自分の娘のように守ってあげて
ふざけると怒ってあげて
心配してあげると その人々はもう大学を辞めて大人に社会人になっても先生ってありがたく言うんでしょうに
だからこんなわかりやすいことをよく否定しますから
そういうわけで 自分が自分を守る
の教えをブッダの教えなの
そういうふうに偉大なる教え
世の中に教えたブッダなんですけど
お釈迦様は完全な心ですからね
完全たる智慧だから 一切病気治したんだから
一切精神的な苦しみ苦しみを治ったんだから
お釈迦様に何もいらなかったんです
しかし この肉体に物質入らなくちゃいけないんです
お釈迦様の弟子たちは阿羅漢果になったんだから
何もいらないんですね
でも肉体はまだあるんだから
物質は必要なんですね
それでこのお布施するというね
習慣が現れたんです 最初はタダでしたけど
誰にも迷惑をかけないことで食べ物を得ていたんだけど
それからお布施するようになっちゃって
これで皆様がそのお布施
仏法僧にお布施をするんです
人類のためにやっているんです
だから こんな徳の高いお布施は普通できません
皆様の仏教の在家の方々の商売をやっている方々のお布施でからお布施のおかげで 2600年
浄土仏教は ついているんです
我々は爆弾は持ちませんよ
棒一本も持ちませんよ
人を殺すために 誰とも喧嘩もしない
落ち着いているんだけど
仏教は生き続くんです
仏教徒たちもブッダの教えを守れば
それほど力強い守りがないんです
怒気を持って怒りに憎しみで狂ってる人をが
慈悲の心の人を殺そうとしたら殺せないんです
殺しに行け あ お元気ですか？とこっちが聞くんだから
重い荷物大変でしょうと聞いちゃうと
あの あれ スイッチは押せなくなっちゃうんです
だからその仏教はね 皆様方も今行って
これから行っているお布施
昔の方々はそういうサンガに仏法僧にお布施をして
あの仏教を守っている
だからこのお布施がお釈迦様とサーリプッタモクレン尊者は大尊者で良尊者ですけど
すべてのサンガに皆様方はお布施をするんです
それで仏教が衰退しないで
すべての人類のために
これからの人類の幸福のためにも活動して
世に平和と心の安らぎ
苦しみをなくすことをやってくださいという願いを込めてお布施をするんです
ですから 決してこちらに座っている我々を食わしてあげたと思わないでください
そうなってくると 大したことはないよ
一人でご飯食べる食べさせるぐらいは
すごいすごいこと 大したことない
それはこうこういう風にサンガにするお布施っていうのは
ものすごい尊いお布施になるんです
これは最高なもので これより以上お布施はできません
どれくらい徳があるのかというと
消えないんです サンガにお布施したら
その徳が消えるんだけど
あまりにもありすぎる
8億円あるところからね
もう 100円取ったからといってどうったことはないんですね
だから皆様方はいくら長く輪廻転生しても
サンガのお布施の功徳はまだまだ残っている
だから世の中でなんかやけに豊かな人々いるでしょ
どうしても豊かさが落ちませんね
富豪でもうものすごい人々いるんですね
そういう人々はもう過去生でそういうお布施をして
その功徳の利益を得ているんです
我々は何を言ったってもどうにもならん
どうにもならん しかし
これで輪廻を延ばすんじゃなくて
輪廻を延ばすとは苦しみを延ばすことだからね
愚かさを伸ばすことだからね
さっさと真理を発見して
一切現象は無常であると
サッベサンカーニッチャー
それを理解して ものに執着しない心を作って
さっさとブッダの力を借りて解脱に達するようにと必ず誓願しなくちゃいけないんです
はい  時間になりましたので
これから皆様にこれから行う
サンガのお力によって幸福でありますように
悩み苦しみ かな苦労がなくなりますように
健康でいられますように
今も何か何か病気があったら
それもなくなりますように
精神的な悩みがあったら
そのすべて悩みが消えて明るく生活できますように
毎日心がどんどん智慧が現れて真理を発見しますようにと
それからすべての煩悩なくして解脱に達することができましょうにと誓願いたしまして
3回サードゥ  サードゥ
サードゥ サードゥ  はい
それからあの 皆様のご先祖様方にもこの功徳を回向しましょう
ご先祖様方も幸福でありますように
輪廻転生 輪廻の苦しみから早くもなくなりますように
抜けられますように それから解脱に達することができましょうにと
3回サードゥと言って回向してください
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
はい それから人類を守る神々
仏教 仏教を守る神々 国を守る神々
すべての神々もこの功徳をいただいて
幸福でありますように
幸せでありますように
心軽らかになりましょうね
解脱に達することができますようにと神々にも回向してください
3回サードゥ  サードゥ
サードゥ サードゥ  はい
じゃあはい サンガにお願いします
はい それじゃあ はい それお坊様方が参加していただかないと
仏教活動の法要っていうのはちょっとできなくなってるんですね
そういうのはお釈迦様の決まり決まりで
この独り善がりで活動することは禁止であって
いつでもサンガとして
グループとして活動しなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで あの法要
正式的な法要などになってくると
まあ 4人以上の比丘たちは 4人
最低ですね 比丘たちは必要になるんです
そういうことで 今日もサンガとしてたくさんの坊さんたちが来ていただきまして
その坊さんたちにも健康で
ますます明るく元気で活動できるようにと誓願いたします
はい  サードゥ サードゥ
サードゥ  はい では皆様
明日も苦労しなくちゃいけないんですから
早く終わった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
というわけで 説法は 5,000円程度のものでば十分でしょうね
私ね ご飯食べさせないならば頭が回転しますけどね
私の問題じゃないんです
ご飯持ってきて食べなくちゃいけない
食べちゃったらもう頭がストップしなっちゃうんです
最近ね スリランカではね
まあ頭イカれた連中のおかげで国はハチャメチャになっちゃって
我々は仏教伝来して以来
ずっとお釈迦様のエサカマッスルをね
第1にやってきたんですね
今回はそれはできなくなっているんです
で 危険ですから お寺にでもでも呪縛テロをやろうという計画があって
たくさんこういうアジト調べると
たくさん衣とか鉢とかね
それから在家の女性の服とかね
あのお寺に行く時の着ている白い服とかね
結構見つかっちゃって
それからセキュリティビデオカメラにも
この体全部隠して 黒い色でね
女たちが店に入って ずっとこのシングルの民族の仏教徒たちが着る白い服だけもらって買って
結構大量に買って出ているというね
それはあの事件が起きてからなってますけど
そういうわけで お寺も危ないということでね
気をつけなくちゃいけないことになってますね
だから何人かがね 一人でも頭イカれちゃうといかに危険かと人類にね
ということなんですね
だからもうどうにもならん
そんな理性言っても理解するものじゃないんですね
脳の思考能力を全部壊してるんですね
だから私もイスラム人の説法とかはちょこちょこと聞いてみるんだけど
いかに思考能力を壊すのかとびっくりするほど
そういう風に話を持ってくるんですね
で もっともっと頭がいいんですよ
この間 オーストラリアに住んでるイスラム人の
話を講演聞いていたんですよ
ものすごく上手ですごいユーモアでウィットで
で その人はこの過激的なことをやることにはもう大反対で
だからネットで何のことなく流していたんですけどね
で 私たちはね その人オーストラリア住んでいるんだから
なんでオーストラリアに文句言うんですかと
この人々は我々にいさせてあげて
ものすごく幸せでいるようにしてあげているんだよと
で ここでイスラムの国を作らなくちゃと思うならば
お前ら病気だから自分あの元の国に帰れと
人の国に行ってお世話になって
その国を破壊するっていうのはね
どういうことかと だからまあたまにそういうまあ理性しゃべるイスラムの先生たちもいるんです
で まあすごい言葉のイントネーションとかね
言葉の使い方とフレーズの使い方で判断すると
相当の頭の良い知識人だなとね
って思いましたけどね
それでこのテロを講演する連中の話を聞くと
その連中もすごい口が達者なんですね
でも 口を開けたところから終わるところまですべて屁理屈で
で 脳みそを壊す話ばっかしで
理論はいたって単純 唯一の神はアッラーのみである
他何やってもアッラーを侮辱しているんだと
アッラー侮辱する人々には生きる権利はないんだと
だからそれを処分して処置するのは
アッラーに対するこの上のない賛嘆であると
そういうふうに話を持っていくんですね
だから お釈迦様の教えはいかにすごいかということは
そういう悪いケースででも我々には勉強できるんでしょうね
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと
頭いかれて何か概念を持ってきて
で  それは そのまま信じ込まなくちゃいけないし
だから初めから信じるっていうこと自体は問題ある
っていうのは仏教の立場なんです
信じるとは証拠ないからなんです
証拠あるならば信じる必要はないんです
事実です だからFACTSという事実に基づいて生きるならば
我々にはものすごい平和な社会が現れてくるんです
事実ではなくて 感情を土台にして生きるんだからね
感情は悪なんですよ 好きっていう感情でも
この全部怒りの感情も完全に悪なんですね
感情って主観だから 感情は自分の気持ちだから
自分の気持ちが普遍的な真理であるっていうのはね
ありえないでしょうに
なぜならば 自分の気持ちもその都度その都度変えられますから
この人ならまあまあ死ぬまでもうもう一緒にいけますよといけますよと思って結婚したら
また別れるでしょうに
それから二度と顔を見たくないとかね
その人は住んでる地方にも住みたくないぐらい気持ちが変わるでしょうね
一緒に死んでも悔いはないと思った感情が
そうやって逆感情に変わりますよ
だから感情はファクトだと
感情こそ事実だということほど愚かなことはないんですね
そういうわけでお釈迦様がね
感情のない生き方をね
理性の生き方 いわゆる客観的なデータに基づいた生き方を推薦していて
それから我々に戒めているのは
すべての生命に生命を慈しんでくださいと
で その教えにはかなわない
愛を謳っている宗教はあるんでしょうね
でもすべてこの条件付き愛なんですね
だからなんで条件をつけるのかと
キリスト教の新約聖書の場合はね
まあただ条件なく愛しなさいという風にような言葉はたくさんありますね
ではあるんだけど 動物のことどうするのかと
それは全然考えてないんですね
しかし よくよく見るとね
まあ生命は生命だから
ちょっとは二本足で歩くからといって偉そうなこと言ったっても
動物は何を考えている我々わからないし
言語ないだけで偉そうに自分たちが偉いと思ってるってね
勘違いなんですね はい
そういうことですべての生命がいるから私もいられるっていうことで
お釈迦様が先にあの 誰にも否定できない教えを教えたんですね
それからこのサチッタパリオーダパナ自分の心を清らかにしなさいと
それが道であると ブッダブッダの戒めはそれだよと
だから心ちょっと汚れちゃうと人が爆弾になるんですね
だからよく大学に出て
工学部出てね まあいろいろノウハウを得ると
どれほど危険かと 例えばこの
核兵器とかね まあ核兵器とか
こういう原子世界のね
研究も結構ああいうグループはやってます
アメリカ 大学 いろんなところに行ってね
ああいう技術を身につけて
それで頭いかれちゃうとどうするのかと
だから科学者はありがたくないんですよ
科学者であっても 正しく物事を考える理性に基づいて
慈しみに基づいて生命を愛する思考が
気持ちがないとあまりにも危険なんですね
人間というのは だからおかしく
この人間賛嘆することはよくないんです
人間ほど地球に迷惑な存在もないんです
昔どこか昔々なんかちらちらとテレビで見た映画なんですけど
なんか宇宙からなんか生命体が来て
まあかなりの力ある連中がね
ワンフレーズあったんですね
ヒューマンカインドイズザウイルスオブディワールドというね
フレーズがあったんですね
この地球にあるウイルスは人間であると
映画を作る人々は面白おかしく書く文章なんですけど
なるほどと思っちゃうんですね
本当のウイルスは一番危険なウイルスは人間であるというね
だから私たちはどこにいても最大迷惑という人間の生き方ね
それを直す 直してくださいと
心を清らかにしてくださいと
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 感情で指導されて生きてはいけませんと
慈しみに導かれて生きるべきという
この偉大なる教えなんですね
またいろいろたくさんありますけどもね
今日は難しい話をしゃべる場合でもないんですね
ですから このお釈迦様に手を合わせただけでも
我々はすごいことをやっているんです
我々は唯一 生命の師匠を尊敬しているんです
唯一 人類ではなくて すべての生命に幸福を与える目的で活動したお釈迦様なんですね
ですから 頭を下げるならば
礼をするならば  ブッダしか適した人々
人間はいません ブッダの遊びに心を清らかにした人々は人類の先輩になります
だから その ２つのカテゴリーしかないんですね
そういうことで 怒りで戦いを聖戦にしている場合は
もうなんでそれは信じるのかっていうこともよくわからない
だから他宗教を学ぶなよ
信じるなよ 宗教を変えたら直ちに殺せますよというふうに脅したりはする
イスラム人が宗教を変えないのは
イスラム教は素晴らしいからで
そうじゃないんですよ
宗教を変えちゃうと殺されます
殺せますから 単純 で 唯一預言者がモハメッドだからね
人の話を聞くなよと なんで聞くのかと
そこでコーランでも書いてないことをやっているんですね
そうやって心がイカれることはとっても危険なんですね
私たちの場合でもね 感情があるし
愛情が 嫌があるし 怒りがあるし
落ち込みがあるし そういうものをとても危険で見なくちゃいけないんですね
であの人々ほど危険ではないのかもしれません
だけど それでもまあ 私たちの世界ででもね
時々頭がおかしくなって
何人か無差別的に殺すケースっていうのはもう結構あって
最近ないんだけどね 前はまあ結構そういう無差別殺人事件っていうのはあったんだからね
だからそこでバックで宗教ないんだから
全然問題はしない 普通の犯罪として扱いますけど
我々はそういうことから学ばなくちゃいけない
突然 普通に生活している日本の人が車を運転して
いきなり道路で車 例えばね
秋葉原であったようなね
結構前ね 秋葉原のメインストリートは日曜日車が通らない
みんな一般歩く 歩いたり
フリーウェイになっちゃうんですね
そちらにガーッと車入っちゃうと何人死ぬかわからない
だからその人の目的はもう誰でもいいんだけど
たくさん殺したい だからそこでその人は宗教に洗脳されてないでしょ
その昔ね もうまあ十年ぐらい前かなね
秋葉原の事件はね だからそれは ISIS とかって関係ないんですね
しかし そこで何が見えるのかというと
突然頭がおかしくなった
その結果は人類にすごい迷惑な結果になる
その場合は その人にもう一人に同じ教えを教えて洗脳することはできない
自分の頭イカれて周りに至っても
周りを相手にしてあげない
その代わりに病院に連れて行こうとする
これに宗教が入ってくると
友達にも同じ教えを教えて頭を壊すことはできますね
だから この人間が慈悲の瞑想でヴィパッサナー瞑想で心を清らかにしないならば
ものすごく一人一人我々は危険な状態にいるんですね
だから私は使っている軽い言葉っていうのは
我々はウイルスのキャリアである
ウイルスを持っている
まだ発病していない 何かのきっかけで貪瞋痴が発病するんですよ
爆発するんです そうすると相当な危険なことになっちゃうし
自分も悪を犯して地獄に落ちるし
周りの関係ない人々もその不幸被害者にならなく
被害者にならなくちゃいけないし
だから なぜお釈迦様がね
常にサティの実践 ヴィパッサナー実践
慈悲の瞑想っていうのはハチャメチャ進んで勧めているのは
やっぱり我々は一般人があのウイルスのキャリアですからね
体にウイルス入っていると
ほんのわずかなことで
これはもう活動し始めるんですね
だから このウイルスという危険性をきれいに取り除くことが悟りであって
で 戒律を守ったり お釈迦様の教えを勉強したり
良い友達を作ったり 一緒でも良い環境を作って
悪い人々いるならば その人々挨拶はするんだけど
仲間としては入れないで
気をつけて活動しなくちゃいけないということになっているんです
基本的には まあそれはまあ
ブッダの教えの一番省略的なわかりやすいバージョンなんですね
そういうことで 皆様方はこの
そういう偉大なるお釈迦様に礼をするために
この祭り 祭りではなくて
法要に参加したんですね
お布施についてももうちょこっと喋りたいんだけど
お布施っていうのは この主にこの食べるものをお布施することなんですね
で 食べるものというのは不思議なもので
食べるもので命が成り立つんですね
だからあのブロッコリーをあげているんじゃないんですね
茹でたブロッコリーをじゃああげますと
今茹でたブロッコリー食べたら命がつないぐんでしょうね
40年でも 88 80年でも
生きるためには食べなくちゃいけない
だからこの肉体を老いるのはやめられませんだけど
老い進む  8 80年かけて老いて
まあそれで死ぬとかね
それで 88 10年間生き続けるために必要なものは食べ物なんですね
だから食べるものをあげるとは命をあげることなんです
それは普段も日常生活でも理解してください
皆さんは料理作ってるでしょ？腹が立って
イライラ気持ちで もうもう面倒くさい
こんなことはとかね まあ手抜きしたいとかね
いろいろごまかしするで
そこで怒り割り込んでいるんですね
怒り割り込んで食事作ってあげると
これはとても良くないね
命をあげているんだから
だからいつだってご飯を作るたびに
その命を我々は助けている
命をあげている 命をつなぐために必要なエネルギーを作っているという気持ちでやった方が
食べるものから病気にならないんです
食べて病気になるということは変でしょ？食べて元気にならなくちゃいけないんです
でも 現代社会はみんな病気なんですね
理由を見たら食べたからなんです
他病気っていうのはすごく少ないんです
見る限り もう食べたから病気になった病人のあまりにも数が多いんですね
それは変なんです そうなる必要はないんです
だから食べて病気になる理由 2つあります
作る人が怒り 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみ 欲で作ったと 例えば外食っていうのは
一般的には体に悪いと思っている
思っているでしょう あるいは外食
それ作りとはプロなんですけど
だからおいしく作るんです
そちらでたくさん食べて
おいしく食べて儲かりたいという人を助けてあげます
命をあげますという気持ちはないんです
だから 母親が作った食べるものは
子供が食べて病気にならないね
お腹が壊したとか 何か変なことになったとかは全然ないんです
母親が何か作って子供の口にさせちゃえば
子供は何のことなくそれは飲み込んじゃいます
なんだこりゃとかね 調べようともしない
ちょっと子供にとって
ちょっとこれまずいな
食べたくないなとか気持ちがあっても
食べなと言ったらガブッと飲み込むんですね
そちらにすごい信頼と愛情が入っているんですね
だから 母親が子供が健康で元気に成長してほしいという気持ちが入っているんですね
それで病気にならない
その子供が大人になってからなんですね
だから 一料理作る方々は
これはすごい修行だと思ってね
徳を積むことやと思ってね
生命に命をあげている
たとえスズメに餌をまいても
あの気持ちを忘れないでください
スズメさんたちに命をあげているんです
ですから その気持ちになると
そこは慈しみが働いているんです
だから 作る人の心が汚れると
食べるものはその分は毒が入って毒のエネルギーが入っているんです
それから 食べる人も汚れた心で食べると
美味しいから食う 豪華な食べ物だから食う
珍しいものだから食う
もったいないから食うとか
そんな話でしょ この壊れてる体に必要な材料を入れてるんだよという冷静な気持ちがない
だから 我々のグループにはみんなにテキストを配ってますよ
食事習慣というね それが清らかに食べる秘密なんです
持ってない方々は持って行って食べる前に唱えてください
そうすると 食べるものは毒に回さないんです
一日出家法要会でもちゃんとそれはもうしっかりと教えているんです
そういうことで  2つの原因が揃っちゃうと
それで汚れた心で作った人の料理は汚れた心で食べればもう話にならないね
2つの場所で毒が入っているんです
だから脂っこいものは体に悪いとかね
もう脂肪多いものは悪いとかね
そういう話はあんまり意味がないんです
たまたまその日で脂肪が多いものしか手に入らない材料は
それでも尊い気持ちで命をあげているんだと
作る食べる人も あ これは壊れている部品を補給していることやという気持ちでやると
あれはもうコレステロールには回らないんです
エネルギーとして活動するんですね
そういう風に この心を清らかにするということは
もう至るところに入ってきて
今 お布施について喋った時でも
いかに心清らかに このお布施ということは大事かと
これ お布施する場合はサンガ
んだから 誰に命をあげるのかというと
偉大なるブッダの教えに命をあげているんです
ブッダの教えが世に広げれば
どこでも幸せがあるんです
災難はないんです だから苦しみっていうのは九十九パーセント精神的なんです
ブッダの苦しみのリストを見ると
体の痛みはそんなに相手にしていないんです
体が痛い もうそれで終わり
体は痛く感じなかったら生きていられない
だから足が痛い 腰が痛い
頭が痛いところは必要な痛みなんです
どこかでちょっとうまく働かない場合は
痛みで それは我々に忠告するんですね
だからその痛みはなくすわけじゃないんで
それだったらメスで麻酔
麻酔かけた状態な体は何も感じないんだと
それでは死んじゃいますよ
だからそれがブッダが発見する必要ある真理じゃないんです
でも それすら人間はわかってないんです
痛いのは嫌というふうにいっぺんに思うだけ
痛くなるのは必要な嫌ではなくて
しかし 他の痛み 悩み 落ち込み
などの憂い 悲しみ すべて心の世界なんですね
ですから この心を清らかにすると
悩み苦しみがなくなるんですね
苦しみを乗り越えることはできるんですね
それでお布施する人々はサンガにこのブッダの教え
それ教えというのは 人を通して人がなければ教えがないんだからね
だからサンガを代表してお布施をするんですね
お布施があるから お坊さんたちも何の心配することもなく
力いっぱいブッダの教えを世に広げるために活動する
だから二千六百年もそういうことをやってきたんです
それでお釈迦様の教えでは
あの 例えばご飯を食べて
口を洗って 口に水を入れて
これボコボコと洗って
この残り食べかすが微生物の栄養になりますようにと言って外へ出したら
例えば公園でご飯を食べて
ちょっと水を口に入れて口を洗って
ペッと水を出すでしょ
その瞬間ででも この食べかすが生命の栄養になりますようにと思ったら
それすら布施でしょうと
ダーナでしょうと それぐらいやったら十回生まれ変われる徳が積んでるんだと
一回ですけど やったのはね
それぐらい命あげたら命いただく
そこで動物にあのお腹いっぱいご飯食べたらもっと徳があるんでしょうね
で 極悪人の人間にでもお腹いっぱいご飯食べたら
その場合 千回 生まれ変われる力になっているんです
悪を犯さない普通の人にあげたらもっと徳が高いし
もう戒律を守っていない
しかし 三宝の帰依している人
その人にはもっと千回かける十なんですね
一万回 の徳になるんだと
そうやって徳の掛け算があります
その中で五回守る人 八回守る人
十回守る人ね それから沙弥出家している人
比丘戒を受けている人にあげれば
そうすればもう十百万
千万とか 数えが大きくなっていくんです
その中でも慈悲の瞑想をする人にあげたら
ものすごく清らかな徳になるんです
慈悲の瞑想をすると 生きる権利
その瞑想で生きてもらっているんで
生命を慈しむことで だから人が慈悲の瞑想をするならば
まあそこは清らかなダーナになるんですね
だから我々にも締めているんだけど
お布施もらう時は必ず慈悲の気持ちでやってくださいと
食べる時でも そうすると
あれがすごい清らかな行為になるし
あげた人にもものすごいたくさん徳が入るし
食べる人も借金なく済みます
で 命生きる権利をいただいているんだからね
でないと借金になる場合もあります
人を騙して心は汚れたままで
汚れてないよと言い張ったりして
それるとちょっと不正にご飯取ったことになりますね
それは徳と同じく借金もかなり厳しい計算になるんですね
はい で そのリストの中で一番上にやるのはサンガ
サンガダラなんですね
サンガにすると お布施はそれ以上は何もお布施できませんと
だから皆さんは今日やったのは
まあブッダお釈迦様の教えによると
一番最高な徳が得られる法要ですね
だから消えない 解脱に達するまで消えない
人を幸福にさせる じゃあ
ダーナしたら何を輪廻するとき得られるのかというと
やっぱり命をいただくんですよ
命をいただいたとは 生まれただけじゃなくて
生まれたらその寿命を全うしなくちゃいけない
寿命を全うするために
周りの生命は協力しなくちゃいけない
周りの人は 生まれてきた人はものすごく嫌がるんだったら
もうゴキブリが生まれたような感じで
もう殺虫剤かけて殺しちゃうんですね
そんな感じになっちゃうんですね
ですから 何のことなく無事に生きられるためのエネルギーをもらっちゃうんです
例えば人間に生まれたら
いち健康な体になる それから周りに好かれる
周りがこの人を見ると楽しくてしょうがない
そうするとそこで生きられるんです
仕事の面接に行ったっても
向こうがあー この人はいい人ですね
可愛いねとかね 捨てたくない
そばにいてほしいっていう気持ちになるんです
そういうふうにこの業が働くんです
だから どこに生まれたっても
そのその環境に合わせて
業が適切に影響を上げて生かしてあげるんですね
寿命を全うすることはできます
突然死ぬということはないんですね
はい そういうふうに このどこに生まれていても寿命があって
それはワンナっていう言葉なんですけど
いわゆる体の調子ですね
同じ仲間にかなり好かれるような
気に入られるように なんか頭の印象が残るような体格
見た目 そうなるんですね
時々いろいろ障害を持ってる人もいるんだけど
障害よりはなんか可愛いね
この人って思う人いるでしょ
なんか惹かれてしまう
だから障害は障害 別な問題ですけど
やっぱり生きられますね
それだったら 可愛いと一緒に気持ち悪い入っちゃうとどうなる？可愛いではなくて
障害とは気持ち悪い 逆にシュッと障害があるみたいだけど
やっぱり可愛いんですねと
なってくる その人の問題ないんです
そういう感じで このお布施の功徳が輪廻する間では機能します
で それは俗世間な話で
お布施に力があるのは命をあげたからではなくて
自分がある程度欲を捨てたからなんです
欲っていうのは わがままで自分の利益しか考えない感情なんですね
この感情を戒めた ね あげましたからね
必ず自分のものをあげなきゃ布施になりません
人のもの取ってあげても
[笑い] だから自分のものだったら
自分には暴風的に執着できます
自分の給料は自分頑張っていた給料だから自分のものなんです
で 筋肉はすってきます
[笑い] だからそこであげるんですね
だからあの欲を戒めたんですね
で それがすごくいいとこになりますね
だからいかに感情を戒めるかっていうことによります
そういうことで それを使って感情はきれいさっぱり感情から離れますという希望をすれば
心がそういうシステムで働くんです
とにかく輪廻転生を延ばそう延ばそうではなくて
プログラムちょっと変えるんです
心は無限にプログラムを作って作って
常にプログラムをアップデートしますよ
だからどんな風に生まれても
生き方によって自分のプログラムがアップデートになるんです
だから正しくアップデートしない
みんなウイルスいっぱい入ってるプログラムをインストールして
元のオフィスをもう壊しちゃうんですね
だから善行為しなさいっていうのは
正しく自分の心のプログラムをアップデートしなさいっていうことなんですね
だからたくさん徳を積まなくちゃいけなくなっているんです
ですから 皆様方はこの功徳によって解脱に達しますと
煩悩をなくしますと希望したら
その方向へプログラムを調整されます
そういうことで まあこれ以上しゃべれません
もう足が痛い もうたまらないぐらい
[笑い] お釈迦様のおかげ様で
皆様にもたくさん徳を積むことができましたので
皆様方は幸福でありますようにと誓願いたしまして
解脱に涅槃に達することができますようにと誓願いたしまして
話を終了します どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
はい それからあの 回向
功徳を回向することが必要でありまして
あの 今日の法話をなすった方々に対して
功徳の言葉を功徳を回向する言葉をかけなくちゃいけなくなっています
で この中のゼロ法要のね
会場費は布施していただきました
それは前田真理子様なんですね
で かなりの金額になりますので
あの 例えば前田真理子様に幸福でありますように
三宝の御加護が常にありましょうにと回向します
その回向の目的は あの自分のお母様が
あの ものすごく苦労して
あの介護をしているんですね
だから自分のお母様のことがあまりも
あの うーん 大変だと悲しみという悲しみではなくてね
ものすごい頑張ってるんだから
このお母様には精神的にすごく力つけてあげたいという
あの子供の気持ちでもあります
親孝行でもありますから
この特に自分のお母様にがすごい健康で
あの楽しく明るく生活できますようにという希望でございます
まあそれからもう介護を受けてる方もお父様でしょうね
まあそれで家族の皆様方に
このすごい大変な金額のこの功徳を布施した
その功徳によって 病気がなくりますように
長生きできますように
どこに生まれ変わっても健康で長生きできる
明るい人生生活できる
明るく生活できますように
心が煩悩からなくなって
極楽の幸福である涅槃解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
サード サード サード はい
それから皆様にお供養する人がいらっしゃいまして
そのアンド アンドウサギさんアンドサトルさん
[笑い] 二つ二回呼んでしまって
それからあの皆様に あの当事者の方
お坊様方にあの 食費の布施がございまして
皆様にもあの布施といったらまずいですね
まあ食費の布施で で 皆様の昼のお弁当も用意してありまして
まあそれは偽名になってますから
あの  匿名です  匿名 偽名で
偽名だと  これ匿名理論ですか？日本語わからないことバレちゃいますね
まあそれも実は安藤サクラ様と早川京子様のお布施です
だから名前忘れてくださいね
匿名で あの別のお布施してね
名前を自分で言い換えるという気持ちは素晴らしいんですけど
決して良いことをして
それは隠蔽しないですからね
特にテーラワーダ仏教では良いことをしたらみんなにそれ発表するんです
なぜならば いいことをしまったねと思う方々にも功徳になります
ですから 皆様方にも功徳になりますからね
そういうことで あの 特にあの早川さんが今日こさんですね
あの まあまたちょっと希望がありまして
自分の弟とかお兄ちゃんです
お兄ちゃんでしたっけ？英訳でちゃんとだからわからない
あの ちょっと病気で大変な状態になっていて
もうなんとか安らぎになってほしいという希望があります
病気っていうのは 治る場合も治らない場合もありますから
それはもう天道の運命でもありますからね
まあそこであえて落ち込んではいけないし
そのまま受け止めるしか方法はないしな
それでも あの この京子様が
早川さんがね なされたこの功徳によって
ベッドの上ですね あの
その兄弟の方がね 病気になってる方にね
すごく安らぎがありますように
できることなら病気がね
治りますようにと それから心清らかになりましょうと
安穏に生活できますようにと
死後 悪いところに行かないで天界に生まれ変われますように
だから解脱に到達することができますようにと祈願いたします
それから 早川さんの家族の他の皆様方にも
この功徳が返りまって幸福でありますようにと
解脱に達することができますようにと回向いたします
サード サード サード それから皆様に年賀としてお配りするこの諸天宝輪像のカードとありますね
そのカードはこの清浄寺のお寺のあの布施でございます
そういうことで それだけじゃなくて
協力した皆様方も自分の体力で
自分の能力で ものすごくお布施をしています
お釈迦様のこのお祭りにいろんな形で参加する方々
みんなお布施の功徳を積んでいらっしゃいます
それから我々はみんな集まって
ブッダのために 偉大なる方のために
唯一この世界で会った
頭下げて礼をするべき唯一な存在で
それから師匠としてのすべての生命の人間だけじゃなくてね
唯一の師匠であるお釈迦様に礼をする
お釈迦様のことを念じることだから
様々な形ですごい苦労なさったんだから
医者の方々はね すぐあっという間の時間でこの舞台も用意しましたしね
それからこれまた片付けなければいけないしね
そういう大変な仕事いっぱいありますから
それすべて自分の命で功徳をお布施したことになりますね
体力と知識 能力 それからマネジメントという管理能力などなどは
すべて自分の体で持っているものだから
それは自分の体をお釈迦様にお布施したことになる
すごい大きな功徳なんですよ
あの物品の功徳ははっきりしますけど
これはもっと幅広い功徳になります
そういうわけで 医者とともに様方
いろんな形で協力した皆様方
いろんな奉仕をした皆様方
それから最後にも皆さん参加して皆様方なかったら何もない立場ですからね
参加した方々もものすごい功徳を行っていますので
皆様方に毎日仏法僧のご加護がありますように
すべての悩み苦しみがなりますように
それそれ皆様方の希望
願望が叶えられますように
健康で明るく生活できますように
毎日心が徐々に清らかに清らかになって
亡くなる時 本当に素晴らしい清らかな心で最後を経験できるようにと
それから涅槃に一緒に達することができるようにと誓願いたします
サワディールー サワディールー
サワディールー  スマナサーラ先生ありがとうございました
えーと 決まっているのはここまでなんですけど
この後は割と漠然とした感じのやっております
例年ですと いつもスマナサーラ長より午前中の短いご法話をいただきまして
御膳が終了という形になっておりますが
今年はいかがいたしましょうか
じゃあ短い話をします
私はね 毎日毎日 まあ年取ると世の中のことを観察していくと
毎日びっくりします 何にびっくりしますかというと
お釈迦様っていうのはあまりにも不思議で
経典に書いてあるような方なんですね
誰 人間 生命 誰にもブッダって何者かと把握し得ないんだと
それぐらい偉大な方であると
それはものすごく身にしみて経験するんですよ
なんでそういうことを言うのかというと
最近 自分の国でものすごいアメリカのテロ事件に次に大きなテロ事件があって
たくさん教会に参加しようと爆破されて
お寺の計画は爆破になっちゃったんだけど
お寺爆破する計画は もうかわいそうにたくさんの人が死んじゃったんですね
だから宗教は間違って理解している
だからあれは間違いだとダラダラと言うんだけど
イスラムの方々はね 宗教は間違って理解していても
残酷な行為をする勇気が出てくるならば
その教えに問題があるんです
何かしら不安 なんて言いますか
曖昧で中途半端であるんです
ところが 特にコーランという聖書なんか読んでみると
この怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨みなどは肯定しているんですね
相手をちゃんと区別してみんなを恨んでくださいと言ってないんだけど
まあ最低神を信じていないグループぐらいは恨めと
だからそこは自己矛盾であることをその方々は理解しないんですね
すべて神様が作ったならば
一部は一部を恨んでいいわけじゃないんです
神様が作った一部を殺していいわけじゃないんです
それこそ侮辱 冒涜なんですよ
自分たちが信仰している神に対して
あるイスラムの女性が我々の教会に出て
ちょっと顔を出しただけなんですけど
見たらいかにも仏像があるんだから
あーいかんだ これは仏像を崇拝しているところに来たんだとびっくりしちゃったんだけど
それでも彼女は信心深いですからね
私にまあ あなた方は神に対して何考えているのかと言ったら
私はちょっとした言葉で言ったんですね
あのね 神様って全知全能でしょ？と本人に聞いたんです
そしたら はい そうです
神様は過去 現在 未来全て知ってるでしょ？はい
そうです 全てこの世の中で起こることは神様の計画通りに起こることでしょ
はい そうですと 神様が知らせて何も起こらないでしょ
はい そうですと 本人が一番調子に乗り上げてるんですね
私は神のことをよく知ってるんだと
それで私はですから 我々は蟻一匹見ても
それは神様が作ったものであると
ゴキブリ見ても植物を見ても
それは神様の作品ですから
尊い気持ちで接するんだよと
何一つにも邪魔しない
迷惑をかけないという主義ですと
だから私はその人に神を否定する意味がないんだから
神を否定もせず 肯定もせず
我々の生き方を説明したのです
一切生命が幸福でありますようにという生き方で生きていますよと
ではコーラン持ってきて
あんた方は共同体で言ってみなさいということなの
だからそこで逆転したんですね
だから人々は自分勝手で考えて
いろんな悪いことをすること自体が仏
だから本人がそこにあなた書いた本でも
英語で書いた本でもないんで
私の仏教学びたいという気持ちにサッと変わったのです
残念ながら英語で書いた本がないんです
英語のところから日本語が違いますからね
で そういうことで ブッダの教えはいかに素晴らしい教えだと
蟻一匹にも我々は迷惑をかけない
自然に迷惑をかけない
動植物に迷惑をかけない
みんな仲良く兄弟と思ってお互いに協力し合って生きてみましょうと
植物は我々を助けているでしょう
植物消えたらどうやって生きてるんですかね
だからもう母親 父親 植物
どちらが偉いんですかね
みんな命を助けてるでしょう
そこでもゴキブリだけ取り上げちゃって
害虫という日本語でよくある名前が害虫というのは存在しないんですよ
そういう風に差別してね
自分が怒るんでしょう
例えば害虫ということを考えてください
畑なんか作っている方々は
もう害虫 虫が入っちゃうと気持ち悪くて怒って自己破壊してるんですよ
なんで虫さん来ていて
なんか私がせっかく作った野菜食べてるんですねとかね
お金ぐらい払ったらどうですかねとか
ちょっと冗談でも言ってくれれば
楽しいですよ 教科書なしに勝手に食いあがっちゃってとかね
そうやって優しくて 自分との仲間として見てみればどうですか
たとえ自分の野菜を一部食べたと
そうすると不思議なことが起こるんですよ
慈しみ広げちゃうと 害虫は存在しない
お互いに協力して 自分自分の世界で生きるということになる
私は実際例を聞いたこといっぱいあります
この農業をやっている方々も
本当に慈しみでやると
ほんの一部だけ虫たちが食べて元気で生きてる
人間の分はちゃんと残してあげる
そう そういうふうな このなんと美しい世界作れますよ
死んでからどんなことがあるとも知らない
天国に極楽浄土にって言ったり
もうそういうへばに行く必要はないんです
この世 楽園に作れますよ
いたって簡単で いたって早い
これ十年かかるものじゃない
しかし 人間というのは無明で生活するんだとお釈迦様はおっしゃったんですね
だから目を明るさ 智慧を教える教えは否定するんです
無明の教えだったら 両手上げて受けるものです
怒りを謳っているならば
戦いを謳っているならば
我々は特別人間であると
選民であると謳っているならば
もう受けるんですよ その教えは
なぜ受けるのかと その中にあるのは
自我 差別 憎しみ 他を見下見下すこと
ところ それから共存ということが否定する気持ちなんですね
殺して何が悪いのかってへっちゃらという世界ですから
まあブッダの教えはちょっと理解しづらいことになっていますね
例えば植物みたいな古いのお母さんもお父さんとかいいですね
優しいですね 私たちを全てみんな守ってるんだよと思うと気持ち悪いですね
どういうことですか？植物なかったら酸素がないでしょう
それにわかる人だったら
この二酸化炭素が このあのローマンウォーミングというね
地球温暖化問題ですね
解決できます いたるところで緑を作っちゃえば
こんなに屋根があるんだから
植物切って建物作ったでしょうね
屋根の上に苔でも作っておけば
どこを見ても緑 緑 緑作っておけば
それで酸素を出してくれるでしょうに
そうすると一部一部燃やした燃やしても見事なバランスを取っているでしょう
だから まあ微生物のおかげでね
納豆も食べられるし 豆腐も食べられるし
味噌汁も食べられるし
いっぱい発酵した食べ物もあるでしょう
酒のことはちょっと置いておきますけれど
で だから我々は命あるものをすごく美しいということは
お釈迦様がおっしゃった教えなんですね
松井会長様がね かなり難しいと言ったんだけど
この程度は難しくないでしょ？かっこいいでしょ
だから仏教はいつでもすごいかっこいい
堂々と胸張って言える教えなんです
はい それでそういう教えですから
私たちの師匠です 偉大な師匠です
誰にも否定できないように語ったんです
ブッダの力はものすごく偉大なる力で
お釈迦様っていうあらせるだけでもすぐ幸せになるんです
これ偶像崇拝じゃないんです
我々は偶像崇拝しません
我々は師匠に手を合わせているんです
師匠に頭を下げているんです
師匠と同時に 我々は父親と思っているんです
聖なる父親 だから父親に頭を下げているんですよ
偶像崇拝じゃないんです
ただ 仏像があった方が気持ちが落ち着く
それだけの話です はい
それでお釈迦様が生まれた瞬間に
それはブッダにしかできないこと
それはお釈迦様がおっしゃっているんです
生まれてすぐ その日からすぐその日でしょ
喋れたんです 歩いたんです
ほんのちょっと 長く歩いたんです
たくさん歩いたわけじゃないです
そこで その瞬間からもう生命の中で偉大なる人っていうことを証明するんです
で されて この言葉を語ったと
経典には入ってますね
唱えます アゴーハマスミローカスー
ジェットーハマスミローカスー
シットーハマスミローカスー
アヤマンティマーダーニ
ナッティダーニプナンバオー
という芸なんですね そこで私はもう仕方がなく
生命の中で一番トップになりましたと
トップとして生まれたんだと
みんなの先輩として生まれたんだと
みんなの先輩だと まあまだ赤ちゃんですね
謝ってまだこれからもう二度と生まれませんと
これは最後の生まれであるということを語った
その時は自分自身のことを見たら
まあ大変なことになっちゃう
すべての生命よりは自分の方が徳が高くなっているんだと
...ということは まあ責任重いという気持ちで
まあ歌った芸でしょうね
それで長い間普通の生活をして
三十五歳になったところで完全たる悟りを開くんですよ
お釈迦様 年間いろいろいろいろいろいろ試していたんですよ
教えを試しても お釈迦様の知識に知識にさえ敵う人はいません
だから一日 二日 三日で相手の宗教は全部知り尽くしたのです
そこで禅定に入る能力があった仙人たちもいたのです
この禅定能力 要するに超能力ですかね
現代的な言葉で言えば
安っぽい言葉で言えば
そういうのを身に付けて本物を求めたのです
お釈迦様は行って 一日
二日 一週間で全部わかる
それでこのアーララーカーナという仙人のところに行って
弟子として入って教えをさせた時にて
この先生の教えは その先生は
この知識で論理で組み合わせて言っているわけじゃない
だからおしゃべり屋じゃない
この先生は何か精神的な経験があるんだろうと思って
先生できるなら私もできる
先生は人間でしょ 私も人間でしょ
先生は努力するならば
私も努力できるという気持ちで修行してみたら
さっと先生と同じぐらいの精神状態に達したんです
達したところで先生のところに行って
先生 先生の説法なさるのはこういう経験があるからでしょう
実は私もそういう経験は得ているんだよと言ったら
先生は現代人みたいに嫉妬しなかったんです
びっくりしちゃったんです
私は長い年月 みんなに弟子に教えるんだけど
誰一人も私と同じ精神境地になっていない
でも 若いのにあなたは素晴らしい
ですから この今から師弟関係はなし
あなた知っていることは私が知っている
ヤマンジャーミのダンパンジャーナス
私が知っていることはあなたは知っている
だから私も年だからね
弟子たちを指導してください
その瞬間なんで お釈迦様のこの革命的なところ
お釈迦様考えるんですね
この精神的な境地に達したからといって
輪廻の苦しみは消えます
精神的な悩みの苦しみはなくなります
ですからなくなりません
ですから これは解脱の道ではないということで出ていくんです
師匠が弟子同じ格であると
師弟関係終わって平等になったと
ものすごい金メダルで卒業証を出してるもんで出ていくんです
そういう風に先生二人から瞑想を教えてもらって
それから いや これはもう私で発見しなくてはいけない
禅龍 それで一切固定概念
先入観 全て全て 今まで勉強したものは全て全て
自分が昔から持ってきた能力はあります
それはすごいと思って
完全に清らかな心で却下
的な心で自己観察を始めたんです
それで一晩で悟りに達するんです
達して一週間 二週間ぐらい経ったところで
どうなったのかと この自分が悟ったことは言葉に入れ替えて
言葉の世界ではないんだからね
言葉に入れ替えて考えると
これは因縁法則でしたよと
見つけたのですね で それからそこで喜びを歌うんですね
悟ったという喜びを これだけ皆さん覚えているでしょうね
アネーグジャティサンサランサンダーサンガニンビサン
ガハカーヤカンガウェーサントゥ
ドゥッカージャティプナップナ
ガハカーカニントーシ
プンネーランナカーシー
サッマンテーファーシュカーバンガー
ガクータンウィサンキタング
ウィサンカーレガタンチッタン
タンナーナンカエマンジャラーという芸です
それは難しい 最初の赤ちゃんの時の芸とは違います
無始なる過去から 私は生まれて死んで
生まれて死んで歩いてきたんだと
終わりなく歩いて輪廻転生して苦しんできたんだと
私は何か探っていましたよと
この家を作るのは誰です
家っていうのは体です
生です 命です この命を作る人は誰でしたと
神様がいなかったんです
悪く言えば なぜかというと
神を拝むためではないんです
ドゥッカージャティプナップナ
生まれては死ぬは 生まれるは死ぬは
これが苦しいんだ 大変だ
皆様の生きてきてよかったと思ってるでしょ
本当に良かったんですかね
赤ちゃん生まれたら ああ
おめでたい おめでとうございます
おめでとうです 赤ちゃんにとっては
大変な世界に待ち構えているでしょう
逃げられる？何かから
できません だから おめでたい
おめでたいことじゃないんですね
そういうことで 生まれ変わることが苦しいんだよ
だから命を作る人は探していたんだよと
だからその時点で もし神様が見つかったら
お釈迦様はその神様は一番敵に回すんです
私の敵はお前だという発音です
でも神はいなかったんです
しかし こう言うんだよ
ガハカーレがディットーシ
家を 命を作る人よ お前見つかりましたと
ガハクータンウィサンキタン
私はあなたの材料を壊しましたと
全部 ウィサンカールガタンチッタン
心が清らになりました
何も概念もない 何も思考も妄想もない
何もない心になったと
これ例えれば空気になった
空間になったような感じなんです
心が波がない まあ空気も波がありますけど
空間には波がないね そのような心が生まれましたと
それで最後に神様の名前を言うんですね
タンナーナンカエマンチェガ
私は渇愛をなくしてしまったと
ですから 我々を作るのは神ではなくて
我々の心に潜んでいる
潜んでないんです 堂々と活動している渇愛なんです
煩悩なんです 欲なんです
それを捨てれば 心は空間の状態になるんです
それから生まれましたという芸人ですね
それはブッダになってから唱えたウダーナというんですね
歓喜の言葉 喜びを表す言葉
それで 年年間みんなに真理を語って
最後に一言葉で語ってやめたんです
その最後の一言葉は 仏教のキーワードで
皆様 ヴィパッサナー瞑想を実践する方々は知っていることで
常に気づく 不放逸になりなさいと
不放逸とは気づくことなんです
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 いわゆるサティの実践なんです
皆様 サティの普通のレベルで実況中継するということで理解してはいるんです
それはどんどんレベルが上がる
言葉なくても決勝ことはできるなる
それはすごい集中力が必要なんです
はい ですから 最後の言葉は
ハンダダニビッカレアマンタヤミオーワイダンマサンカーラアッパマーレーナサンパデータという文章で芸ではないんです
ハンダダニビッカレアマンタヤではあなた方に語ります I
コールアポニオということとか
私はあなた方に語ります
ワイダンマサンカーラ
すべての現象は消えるんです
ですから 不放逸で頑張りなさいという一言葉で
well 喜捨の実践しなさいという言葉でお釈迦様の人生が終わったんです
その三つのできること
断行 貪 浄土 涅槃 明日涅槃という仏教
今日我々は思い浮かんでたくさん功徳を積む日になっています
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]よろしくお願いします
私はずっと悩みがありましてね
私の話にはあまり誰も笑わないのはどういうことか
[笑い]私もいろいろネタ言ってるはずなんでしょう
やっとわかりました 理由が
この人々にはもう敵わないね
[笑い]清十さんとかね
で それまたただの無意味な笑いじゃなくてね
ちゃんと仏教のね 意味をよく理解してね
それをまたネタ交じりでね
素晴らしい能力なんですね
そういうわけで期待はありますね
そうすると 日本の坊様方も
日本仏教の坊様方にもね
よくよく元気で明るくて
日本人のためにすごい活躍できるとは思います
えーと まあこれからもう明るさがまるっきり逆になるんです
今日の話には笑ってほしくないんです
あの まずはエピソードを言います
お釈迦様が悟り開いて 四十九日間禅定でいて何もやらなかったんです
で ご飯を召し上がらなかったんです
それはキリスト教に取られちゃって
そのエピソードをね イエス様も四十何日間断食したっていう
山の中に隠れてね っていう話があって
お釈迦様は菩提樹で悟ったことは
この悪魔と戦って打ち勝ったという話まで
それも取られちゃって
森の中にいると イエス様にもサタンが来て
あなたは世界の一番金持ち
一番をリーダーにしてあげるぞとかね
それでイエス様はいや
こんなのはとかね 言ったような話があって
イエスス物語っていうのは
ほとんど仏教の物語をそのままコピーペ
コピーペーストではなくて
こんなコピーしてるんですね
それはキリスト教っていうのはギリシアで作った宗教なんですね
別にイスラエル 教じゃないんです
ああいう人物は一人もイスラエルいなかったんです
だからギリシアなんですね
ギリシアのユダヤ人が作った宗教で
ギリシアには仏教はちゃんと伝えてあったんです
アリストテレスが で それで四十九日間
お釈迦様がしっかりと何もしないでいて
それから最後の四十九日間に至っても
六七週目でちょっとしたご飯を召し上がって
それからちょこちょこと人と喋ることになったんですね
その時なんですね これは真理は人に語れないんだと
人間には理解できないんだと
お釈迦様は考えているのは
人間がこの肉体を持って
この脳みそを持ってね
脳みそには制限がありますから
何でも理解できるわけじゃないしね
肉体にあるからという体力あるからといって何でもできるわけないでしょうに
例えば我々は犬よりはかなり大きい体を持ってるでしょう
でも犬いると走れる？走れない
犬は四キロ歩いたからで
十キロ歩いたからといってまるっきり疲れませんね
じゃあ犬 犬と一緒に散歩をしてみましょう
私たちは疲れるけど ワンちゃんは全然疲れてないんですね
そういうわけで この体に適した体力がありますし
脳みそに適した能力もあるし
それだったらもうこれは全くダメだと
理解できるはずがないということになっちゃってね
じゃあ黙っていると決めたんです
それでお釈迦様には梵天のお釈迦様の友達に知ってる神が梵天の神ですけどね
サハントティっていう名前ですね
で 来てこんなことをしたら困りますよと
だから説法しなさいよと
梵天の神々っていうのは
だいたい人類にとってなんか先輩役をやるんですね
他の人間信仰している神々はまあそんなに先輩
そんな力がないんですね
梵天っていうのは よっぽどの人だったらね
なんとか先輩としてアドバイスしたりはすることもあることあります
だからお釈迦様は梵天のサハンプティ
梵天の言葉を聞いてね
説法することに決めて
それで人を選んでいくんですね
誰に喋るのかと いろいろ人を選んだんだけど
みんな亡くなられていてね
自分の先生たちとかね
頭の良い人々を選んだんだけど
みんな亡くなられていて
最後に仲間のね 在家の時
カピラ城ワスと町でね
一緒にいたカピラ城ですね
そちらに一緒にいた友達五人ですね
選んで 友達だからなんとか喧嘩しながらでもね
理解できてもらうぞってことで
五人びくたちに最初の説法して
それでその五人 エピソードを略します
その五人が悟りに悟りを開く
それでいると ある若い人が来て
ヤサという人なんですけど
裕福な家庭の息子で かなりのお金がある人で
この人はもう在家生活が嫌になっちゃって家出したんですね
夜 夜家出して もう嫌だ
この在家生活っていうのは
あれもやらなくちゃ これもやらなくちゃ
何やっても切りがないんだとかね
とんでもないところやとかね
地獄に落ちてる 落ちたような感じだとか
なんかグーグーと文句言いながら歩いてる
でお釈迦様はそれを知ったんですね
この人はもう家出してるんだと
若い人が だったら何のことなく
じゃあこちらいらっしゃい
それだったらこちらなら大丈夫やと言ったら
お釈迦様が行者みたいに見えるんだから
そちらに行って お釈迦様年上だからね
その時は三十五歳でしたけどね
この人は若い子だからね
お釈迦様と喋ってるんですね
喋って夜喋ってると この人は夜中に悟るんです
若い人は それで朝起きたら家のお坊ちゃまがいないんですね
もしかすると一人息子やと思いますよ
すっごいでっかい家で
すごいお金がある家で
お坊ちゃまいないとみんな大騒ぎしてどうしようかと調べる
どこを調べてもいない
その心配で怖くなっちゃって
みんなハチャメチャ片っ端から調べるんですね
それでお父さんがいても立ってもいられなくなっちゃって
自分の家周りを見るんですね
家といってもすごい大きいものでしょうね
だから庭とかね あちらこちらどこかに遊びに行ってるかどうかとかね
見ていると草履の跡を見つけたんですね
草履っていうのはこれがカヌー道だから
このまあ ソウルは金属でできちゃってね
金でもいろいろ模様があって
かなりな高価な 普通そこに仏普段履かないすごい草履なんです
秋はそれを履いたままで出て行ってるんですね
だからその靴跡が特別
あ これをうちのこの靴の跡やと
だから跡を見てずっと行ったんですね
今みたいな道路を舗装してないんだからね
石の上だからちゃんと跡がつくんですよ
行くとお釈迦様がいるところに行ってしまったんですね
行ったらずっと草履の跡があるんだから
お釈迦様見つけて あの
私のうちの息子が今いるんで探してますよと
それ父親が来るんだから
お釈迦様の指導のもとで
この息子が隠れたんですね
家出した人だからね お父さんというふうにことにならないんですね
だから見ても ヤサという若者が見えない
名前はヤサですね 見えないんですね
だからまあ大丈夫 大丈夫
ちょっと座って ちょっと座って息子に会います
と言ったら もう人外って
だってちゃんと足跡があるんだからね
それでその人と喋る お父さんとお父さんと息子が抱えていた精神的な悩みのことやら
人生のことやら いろいろ喋っていたところで
お父さんが喜び立ってるんですね
それ話を聞いてた息子が阿羅漢になるんです
阿羅漢になったらもう在家には戻れないんですね
それでもう在家に戻らない状態になったってわかったことで
お釈迦様があなたの息子いますよ
こちらにと見せたんですね
そしたらお父さんが もうお父さん仏教徒なんですね
すごく喜んでみんな泣いてるんだからね
あなたは突然いなくなっちゃって
じゃあ一緒に帰ろうと言ったところであそこの息子はお釈迦様の方にいる
どうしますかと困っちゃったとかね
言ったらお釈迦様がお父さんに
この人はもう在家生活にはもう戻れなくなっているんだと
すべて煩悩なくなっているんだと
言うとお父さん喜び立ちしている中ではそれはよくわかるんですね
あ そうです よかった それお父さんにとってはね
言って息子を出家することにして
本人一人で家帰るんですよ
それからこんな人を出家したんだから
仏教はすごい教えではないかと言って
このやささんの友達が人ぐらいに来て
みんな若者 それからすべて出家する
それでお釈迦様の説法を聞いて
みんなはっとしてるんですね
それでちょっとその地方でちょっと暴動が起きたんですよ
仏教に対して お釈迦様は怖い人間やと
格上の一部はみんな期待してる若者たちみんな出家
んだよと いうふうな このちょっと運動もあったし
でもそれはあまり気にしなかったんですけどね
人は勝手に出家するんだからね
別に何やったわけじゃないし
それで結局は阿羅漢たちが世に六十人現れたんですね
お釈迦様と一緒に お釈迦様を入れて六十一人なんですけど
まあこれぐらいまあ世の中に真理をわかっている阿羅漢たちがいる
だから人類のために インド人のためにと言ってないんです
一切の人類のために 神々の幸福のために
あなた方は一人一人で
各地方で真理を語ってくださいと
歴史上最初の伝道活動
歴史上 仏教 他の宗教 誰も伝道活動をやったことはないんです
仏教は世間で初めてなんです
今のキリスト教のミショナリーというのは
あれはすごいマンモス組織なんですけど
世界的スケールでね 仏教はそういう体制小さくなっちゃったんだけどね
でも人類の歴史で最初に伝道という
いわゆる一般人に民主差別
民族差別なく 国のあれ偏見なく人類に語るということを始めたのは
で それでお釈迦様も じゃあ私も阿羅漢の一人ですから
私はこのガヤというガヤってインドに行ったことみんな方々知ってるでしょ
ガヤシーシャシーリシャと言うんですけど
ボーディガヤもありますね
ブッダお釈迦様が悟ったところ
で 今は別のところに行っているんですね
イシュパタナというね
それからまたガヤシーシャというところに戻ったんですね
結構そちらに戻り 戻って伝道しまうと
そのガヤっていうところで
千人の修行者たちがいたんですね
特に火を作って聖火ですね
作って それで神様に賛嘆したり
神様を褒め称えたり 神様の機嫌取ったりする行者たちなんで
まあ千人いたんですね
三兄弟 兄弟三人でたくさん弟子がいて
大きいところ 大きい組織なんですね
その人々のことはすごい人気あったんですよ
人数も多いし うーん 今もガヤシーシャというところはあるんだけど
今もヒンドゥーか何かの宗教の聖地で
結構今の人々はまあ仏教を捨てて元に戻って
元の原始信仰に戻って
未だに信仰は続けています
間違った信仰は そちらにお釈迦様が行って
お釈迦様の伝道の仕方っていうのは
まあちょっと私も泊まってもいいんですか？と
だから千人いるところで一人が泊まったって問題ないんだから
まあ泊まらせてあげたんですね
そこでお釈迦様が自分の能力で
一般人にできない 人々にできない能力を見せて
この人々の興味を引こうかなと思って
いろんな奇跡を起こして見せたんですね
全然あの人々は気にもしない
一つ面白いんだから言いますけど
このお釈迦様に このじゃあ夜泊まってもいいやとあげた場所が
あの みんなサウナとして使っている火を作って
ちっちゃな部屋なんですね
そこで火を起こしちゃうとすごく熱くなっちゃうし
それで人々はその中に入って汗を出して
このサウナ効果なんですね
で まあそれは贅沢なことではなくてね
インドのインドはある程度寒いんだけど
ものすごい強烈な暑い季節あるんだから
体調がすごく悪くなっちゃうんですね
暖房とかあるわけじゃないしね
だからまあ週一回 二回だけでもサウナに入らないと体が壊れる
そこで住んでください
まずすごい生活しにくいところですけど
そこに入れたの そちらにものすごいでっかいコブラがいるんですね
だからだからコブラがいるんだから
この人々も恐らく怖くてサウナに入らなかった可能性あります
お釈迦様がそこに入ったら
コブラは本当に怒ったんです
なんで私が住んでるところに人間来るのかと
言って威嚇するんですね
全然気にしない 結局は蛇がどんな威嚇された
お釈迦様はそれに対応したりしたんだから
コブラが負けちゃって仲良しになっちゃったんです
言ったらまあコブラは自分の鉢に入れちゃう
大人しくしてあげてね
これはすごく友達だから
お釈迦様の鉢に入ってどくろ巻いて寝ている
それでお釈迦様さ いろいろ大騒ぎやったんだからね
やられてる あのうちの蛇さんにとかね
思っていたんだけどね
朝になったらお釈迦様が一人一人にね
あんた方のサグラにいたのはこのコブラですかね
とか 自分の鉢を見せるんで
そしたらそこ大人しく飼っている動物のようにコブラがいるんですね
これは摩訶不思議なことだと
この人には摩訶不思議なことできるんだけど
悟ってないね 我々は悟っているんだよというふうに
自分たちが聖者であると思っていたんです
そうやっていろんな奇跡を見せたんだけど
そんなことやったってもね
こんな変なマジマジシャンみたいなことをね
あんた聖者じゃありませんという
お釈迦様は負けたんですね
結局は だから じゃあ どうしたらね
でもあなた方はね 悟っていると勘違いしているんだと
あんた方は聖者ではないだけではなくて
聖者になる道すらわからないんだよと
言ったところで ああ そうですか
では教えてくださいと
知ってるならば それは聞いたんです
聞いたらもうしょうがない
みんなもう真理はわかったんだから
次から次へと出家して出家して
結局は仙人も出家で死んでしまったんですね
そこでお釈迦様がこの仙人グループを大体川のところにいたんですね
崖のところに連れて行ったんです
ガヤに 今も川も崖のところもありますけどね
崖のところに連れて行って
その上で一つの説法をしたんです
それはこの アーディッタバリーヤーというね
燃焼教と書いたんですけどね
燃えることを例えにする教典なんですね
その教典を聞いて終わったら
説法を聞いて終わって
仙人も悟りに達する 阿羅漢果に達する
最後のお悟り 最終的に達したのです
今日はお釈迦様 我々の師匠でありますから
お釈迦様の一つの教えを
お釈迦様を尊敬する気持ちで学んでみましょうと
それで悟りを引き起こす衝撃ですね
一切は一切の現象は無常苦魔であると直截してもそうでしょう
そうかもしれません それはブッダの考えなどの
ただの考えで 仏教はよく言ってますよ
そんなことはとかね 皆さんもそうでしょうし
他の人もそうでしょう
一切は無常で まあまあ
仏教でそんなに知ってるということで終わっちゃうんです
俗世間 の壁を破る衝撃的な言葉になります
我々は硬い壁を持っていて
この壁を破らないと悟りに達しないんです
俗世間という壁ね 無常ですよ
全部儚いものだと言ったって
まあそう まあまあ 別にということでは
それではダメなんです
執着を断つためには 釈尊が衝撃的な言葉で語った経典の一つはこの炎上経なんです
今度 お釈迦様があえて過激的に衝撃的に真理を語るので
これお釈迦様の初期時代の説法なんです
ちょっと生易しい説法じゃないんです
生きることは延焼しているイメージ
生きるということは ちょっとずつ出来事
出来事 出来事 出来事 出来事の連鎖
その出来事を一個一個燃えている
というイメージ 生きるということは出来事
この出来事は一個一個調べるとすべて燃焼している
だから生きるとはただの燃えること以外何でもないという
それちょっと過激的というかね
話になりますね それであの教えを聞いた比丘たちは阿羅漢果に達します
決して一般人に感動することはできる教えとは思えません
私の感想ですから 大乗のお坊様方の話とはまるっきり逆になっちゃうんです
笑うことはできない これから一般人がなんか面白くないあるいは怖そうな経典やと思うかもしれません
かなり過激的な経典です
しかし 理解していただけるなら
必ず力が湧いて執着が弱くなります
わずかでも理解すると
皆様の心から執着が弱くなります
真剣に理解していたら
その場で悟りに達します
問題ないです それぐらい力のある言葉なんです
この経典は 釈尊が究極の釈尊の究極の教えをでは学べましょう
炎上経 しかし 私は今日
この専修さんに負けたらマスピンだからね
マスはないんだけど なんかちょっと
だから経典は今日そのまま皆様に紹介しないで
その経典の内容はいかに瞑想に使うのかという瞑想バージョンを作ったんです
瞑想 瞑想バージョン 自己観察の瞑想として編集しました
はじめに  そこら辺ちょっと読んでみましょう
イカンサマンバトはガヤヤンイヘルティガヤシーシェサッビンビッグサハセー
ある時 世尊はガヤのガヤシーシャ山に千人の比丘たちと共に住んでおられた
タトルボバガは比丘アーマンです
時に世尊は比丘たちへ呼びかけられた
えーと そこで一切は燃えているというテーマに行きます
サッバンビクビヤアディタン
比丘たちよ 一切は燃えている
一切は燃えている もう何も残らない
残らない 一切とは眼耳鼻舌身意
色声香味触法のことです
それで理性的に理解してください
私たちが思う一切は 自分を置いておいて
自分に見える世界なんですね
お釈迦様は自分に見える聞こえる世界とまとめて自分自身
すべて一切です それ以外は何も存在しないというか
わからない だから分かりやすく言えば
科学的に分析すると 眼耳鼻舌身意と色声香味触法というね
前の六つは感覚器官で
後半の六つは対象 感覚器官に入る対象
要するに生きているということの全てです
サッバンすべて 一切というのは生きていることの全てなんです
では 生きていることは燃えているということになっちゃうんですね
はい これから瞑想に入りましょう
では 観察瞑想を始めましょう
経典は知識で学ぶものではない
今回は皆様 知識使わなくてもいいんです
自分自身に教えを追い押して言いましょう
はい これからご一緒に読み上げましょう
たくさん経典丸ごとですから
ちょっと長いので私は説明あまりしません
私の説明が入っちゃうとちょっとまずい
だからブッダの指導そのまま一人一人念じて読み上げてみる
読み上げることは実況中継と同じく瞑想なんです
だから本当に今日ウェーサーカ祭りでほくろきれいにして書いてあるではないかというふうに覚悟して
一人一人が真剣に読み上げてみましょう
だから読み上げるということは
ただ朗読ではない よく覚えておこう
これは瞑想そのものなんです
いい目と視覚の世界 はい
では始まります 目は一切
目は燃えています 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
諸老死 死 何だけ 苦憂悩によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれています
色 目に見えるものは燃えています
貪欲により 瞋恚という火により
愚痴という火により 生老死によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
はい 燃えています 目は燃えています
目に触れるものは燃えています
何に燃えていますかというと
ラーガーギン パーリ語ではラーガーギナドーサギナモーハンギナ
ジャーティジャラーヴィヤーティソーカパリデーヴァドゥッカドーマナドーマナッスパーヤーセーナという
で 燃えていますということでね
だからそこでもうちょっと観察を続けてこれから持っていきたいんだけど
我々には欲が生まれる
怒りが生まれる 無知が生まれる
この全部どこで生まれるのか
目で生まれるでしょ 目から入った情報を認識して
よく欲になったり 怒りになったり
無知になったり あるいはこちらに出てる
修比苦苦悩というね 苦しみになったり
ジャラーマラーナ ジャーティ
新しいものが生まれる
目からものを見ると 次から次へと新しい命が生まれていくんですね
自分に それから老いること
死ぬこともそちらにあるし
そちらに苦しみがあるというふうな教えなんですね
はい 次に行きます チャックインニャーナンアーディッタ
はい 始めると始めましょう
眼識は燃えています 眼識は燃えています
貪欲という火により 瞋恚という火により
愚痴という火により 生老死
によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
およそ観測によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感覚
それは燃えています 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
諸老死 諸悲苦苦悩で燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
釈尊が説かれますとあえて入れたのは
尊敬の気持ちで大事に思う
釈尊が説かれても冗談じゃないってになってですね
はい それで目の世界 すべてまとめてます
目 目に触れる情報 それから視覚
見えたと感じること 情報
触れたことによって感覚が生まれるんですね
楽苦 不苦不楽と感覚が生まれる
それ以外何も以外何も生まれません
それ一個一個生老病死なんです
それ一個一個から貪瞋痴が生まれるんです
だから見えたではなくて
ここで炎が上がっている
目がただの部品で 見えるものをただの部品で感じるということは
ただどうったことない
感じた命ですから それに十分なのに
そこですーっと燃えているんです
貪瞋痴が生まれている
次 耳 と聴覚の世界 聴覚世界も貪瞋痴で燃えている
始めましょう 耳は燃えている
声は燃えている 耳識は燃えている
耳触 触とサンパスは燃えている
貪欲により 瞋恚により
愚痴という火により 諸老死
諸悲苦苦悩で燃えておいて燃えていると釈尊が説きます
で どんどん自分の体に
自分の命に当ててみてください
およそ耳触によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感覚
それは燃えています 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
諸老死 諸悲苦苦悩と書かれています
はい 次のセクション 今耳で終わりました
全部耳の 耳の世界は燃えている
で 鼻の世界 はい 鼻は燃えている
と燃えている 鼻識は燃えている
貪欲という火により 瞋恚という火により
愚痴という火により 諸老死
諸悲苦苦悩によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
これ味でありますかね
味は燃えている およそ味触によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感覚
それは燃えています 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
諸老死 諸悲苦苦悩によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
そうすると鼻の世界 すべて燃えています
それで舌に入ります 舌と味
味覚の世界 味に執着することも燃えるものですということ
舌は燃えている プラス味は燃えている
舌識は燃えている 舌触は燃えている
貪欲という火により 瞋恚という火により
愚痴という火により 諸老死
諸悲苦苦悩によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
およそ接触によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感覚
それは燃えています 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
諸老死 諸悲苦苦悩によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
はい それで鼻が終わって
それで体のこと 肉体の
体の感覚によって燃えているんです
はい 体は燃えている 触れることは燃えている
心識は燃えている 心息は燃えている
貪欲により 瞋恚という火により
愚痴という火により 笑
怒 思 喜 悲 苦 憂によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
およそ心息によって生じる楽
苦 あるいは不苦不楽の感覚
それは燃えています 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
笑 怒 思 喜 悲 苦 憂によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
それから心の世界 意識と思考妄想の世界
思考妄想も炎でした はい
火は言わ燃えている 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
笑 怒 思 喜 悲 苦 憂によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
法ダンマ 心に触れる情報
概念では燃えている 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
笑 怒 思 喜 悲 苦 憂によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
意識は燃えている 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
笑 怒 思 喜 悲 苦 憂によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
意識ですね 意識 心に情報が触れることは燃えている
貪欲という火により 瞋恚という火により
愚痴という火により 笑
怒 思 喜 悲 苦 憂によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
およそ意識によって生じる楽
苦 あるいは不苦不楽の感覚
それは燃えています 貪欲という火により
瞋恚という火により 愚痴という火により
笑 怒 思 喜 悲 苦 憂によって燃えていると釈尊が説かれます
はい そういうことで心の改革
智慧が現れて解脱に達します
はい それで経典は終わりと
で 終了になるんですね
それはものすごく長い
すごく小さくしてしまったんだから
ちょっとインパクトが弱くなったんですね
だからテキストをもらってでも
一個一個読み上げてみてください
そうすると結構時間 あの 1
時間ぐらいかかると思います
あの この燃えていること
例えば目は燃えている
ラーガーっていうのは欲
貪欲という火によって目は燃えている
瞋恚という火によって目は燃えている
愚痴という火によって目は燃えている
それから じゃあちょっと
精 怒 精という火によって燃えている
怒 痴という火によって目は燃えている
それから 愁ですね そうか
パリデーワ ドッカドーマ
スーパアヤッサ 愁というこの火
まあこれ全部まとめちゃいます
愁かっていうのはもう悲しくてしょうがない状態
パリデーワっていうのは泣けてしまう
これ 泣けてしまうことは
こちらでは一漢字で悲と書いてるだけなんですね
それからすごく苦しくなる
肉体も苦しくなります
心も苦しくなりますね
その苦なんですね すごくパリドッカ
ドーマナッサっていうのは落ち込んでしまう
力が抜けちゃってどうしようもない状態になるんですね
暗くなるんですね 暗くなることはドーマナッサというね
こちらではただ鬱という漢字でそれを入れているんです
それから最後にこのノーと書いている
ウパーヤスっていうのは
まあその後引くんですね
後を引いちゃって引いちゃって困る
大体人々は精神的に病気になる
この後を引くからなんですね
ウパーヤス 忘れられなくなっちゃって
また思い出してしまう
この後を引くことなんですね
だから 目 目はそういうことで
目に見えるも何か見えた
見えたことは 何か視覚が生まれるでしょ
それでこれ残っちゃうんですね
まあ本当はなんでそんなことを残るのかというと
この視覚が生まれて 脳の中で画像を作ってから
そのそちらに好き嫌い
面白くないと感情を残っちゃう
あの感情がもうまたまた思い出させたりする
だから思い出すたびに貪瞋痴が生まれてきて
悩み 悲しみが生まれてきていくんですね
だから悩み 悲しみ 人間の苦しみっていうのは外から来るものじゃないんです
サタンの誘惑に負けてるわけじゃないんです
神の仕組でも何でもないんです
ただ こちらでこういう出来事が起きているんです
すべての生きる苦しみが目で目の世界で起きているんです
あるいはすべての生きる苦しみは耳の世界で起きているんです
すべての苦しみは花の世界で起きているんです
すべての苦しみは 体に何か触れるだけのこと
いたってシンプルでしょ
そこでえらい精神苦しみの世界が生まれてくるんです
それから頭でちょっと考えたりするでしょ
ただ考えただけの話ですけど
そちらに一切の悩み 苦しみ
すべて生まれてくることですね
だから この生きること自体で何のことない行為なんでしょう
そこでなんであとこんなここで苦しみが生まれるんだ
ただ 見たものは綺麗と感じたら別に綺麗それで終わり
それほどかっこよくないと感じたら
まあそれほど まあそれだけのことなんです
しかし それで感覚からこの感情が湧き
湧き上がってくるんですね
それですごく苦しくなって
後まで引いてしまいますね
何年でも後を引いたりする
それで もうものすごくこの体に人々は無駄に執着しているんですね
それで結果として書いているのは
エヴァンパッサン ビクケ スト アリーサコ チャックスピンピ ニッビンダティ ルーペスピ ニッビンダティ チャッ
ク ビンヤーミーピ ニッビンダティ チャック サンパッセーピ ニッビンダティ
ヤンピタン チャック サンパッサパッチャ ウパジティ ヴェーレタン スカンワ ドッカンワ ドッカマスカンワ タンピニッビンダティ
読みましょうか 比丘たちよ
このように観察すると
多聞というのは理性のある比丘は目に関しても見検をし
諸々の色に関しても検をし
眼識に対しても検をし
眼触に対しても検をし
およそ眼触によって生じる楽苦あるいは不苦不楽の感受
それに関しても検をします
こんなことには執着してはいけないという気持ちになるんですね
で 耳の世界 比丘たちをこのように観察すると
多聞の聖弟子は耳に関しても検をし
諸々の音に対しても検をし
耳識に関しても検をし
味触に関しても見もし
およそ味触によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感受
それに対しても見をします
比丘たちをこのように観察すると
他者の理性のある聖弟子は花に関しても見もし
もろもろの香りに対しても見もし
意識に関しても見もし
味触に関しても見もし
およそ味触によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感受性
それに対しても見をします
比丘たちをこのように観察すると
他者の聖弟子は舌に関しても見もし
もろもろの味に関しても見もし
触識に関しても見もし
触に関しても見もし およそ接触によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感受
それに対しても見をします
比丘たちをこのように観察すると
他者の聖弟子は体に関しても見もし
もろもろの触に関しても見もし
心識に関しても見もし
心触に関しても見もし
およそ心触によって生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感受
それに対しても見をします
比丘たちをこのように観察すると
他者の聖弟子は意に関しても見もし
もろもろの法に関しても見もし
意識に関しても見もし
意触に関しても見もし
およそ間違ったね 意触によっても生じる楽苦
あるいは不苦不楽の感受
それに対しても見をします
ニッピンガンゲラジュティ
見をして return し
return のゆえに解脱します
だからすごくわかりやすいプログラムなんですね
見を感じるところまでちょっと観察すると
文章を読み上げるだけなんです
ヴィブッタスミン ヴィムッタミーティニャーナンコーティ
解脱したとき 解脱したという智慧が起こります
だから何か革命が起こるんですよ
心に 要はそれに取るものは何もなくなっちゃうんです
内でも外でも全て燃えている
燃えているんだったらもうできることでしょう
だから燃える例えっていうのは
家が燃えたらあなたの気持ちはなんでしょうか？と家に焦点化してるんです
家が燃焼しているならば
それは となると逃げるでしょうに
その気持ちと これが燃えているということで
では逃げようという気持ちになるわけですね
なんで逃げるかと これはもういいや
もう嫌はもう役に立たない
だから眼耳鼻舌身は役に立たない
色声香味触法は役に立たない
そんなの触れて触れて生まれる
この感覚が役に立たない
すべて燃えている じゃあ逃げようということになる
だからその逃げは解脱ということになるんです
その気持ちになったら
その人はわかっています
心は解放されて解脱に達したと
キナージャーティ これけまあ
ブシタンブラマチリャンカタンカルミヤンナータラニッタッタヤーティパジャーナーティ
生は尽きた 煩悩は完成した
なされるべきことはなされた
もはやこのような輪廻の状態に至ることはないと領受しますね
だから イデオーチャバラマ
釈尊はこうおっしゃった
アッタマナテービクブットバステナビランドン
心にかなった彼らは 彼ら比丘たちは
世尊の所説に感銘をした
イマスピンチェパン これはイマスピンチェパナレイヤーからナシミバンニマーネー
タッサビクサカサスアヌパーダヤアセーチッターニヴィムチェソーティ
これはレイヤーカルナっていう言葉なんだ
そしてこのこっちはジュキと書いてますけど
レイヤーカルナっていうのは詳しく項目ごとに喋ることなんですね
だからたくさん項目がありますよ
サーって瞬間で終わったんだけど
ものすごく長くすると長いんです
だから今問題は 経典を読む人々はほんのワンページにも至らない
1ページの4分の1程度の経典しか見つからないんです
本当はすべて省略しているので
すごい長い経典なんです
伸ばしちゃうと 喋る場合はすべて伸ばして一つ一つ喋る
だから皆さんは瞑想する場合は
この項目一個一個取って念じれば十分です
声を出して念じてもいいし
ただもうもうとちょっと頭の中で回転してもよろしいのです
必ず心はものはものすごく確実に清らかになるのです
燃えている 貪瞋痴で燃えている
貪瞋痴で燃えているのか
最低皆様はそのフレーズだけを覚えてください
生きている場合は 何かを聞こえると
これは貪瞋痴で燃えている
何か食べたりする場合は
この味は味覚は貪瞋痴で燃えている
弁当を見たら あ これは貪瞋痴で燃えている
弁当は燃えていないんです
見る自分の心は煩悩で燃えている
そういう風に それで食べる時感じますが
美味しいと感じるで それは事実ですね
それを美味しいと感じるところで楽なんですね
楽の感受性 あ これが燃えている
貪瞋痴で燃えている そういう風に皆様の呪文として貪瞋痴で燃えているというフレーズを覚えててください
その方が携帯できます
すべて経典そのまま丸ごと携帯できない場合は
この一つのフレーズでも構いません
その経典を聞いて 千人のお坊さんたちが悟ったんです
そして この呪気が解かれたことで
彼ら千人の比丘たちの心は執着なく
照により解脱した 終わり
で うん そういうことで
このこれは普通のヴィパッサナー瞑想よりはかなり進んだところでやるセクションなんですけど
この本当はパーリ語で読むとあまりにも怖くなるぐらい
このお釈迦様の力が入っているんですね
それから簡単に暗記できるようにも解かれているんです
私はこれ 日本語訳で一応一応いろいろ足が引っ張られてしまったんだけど
パーリ語だったらダラダラダラダラダラダラと言えるような言葉でお釈迦様が語られているんですね
例えば チャックルーパチャックヴィンヤーナチャックサンパッスチャックサンパッスジャミーダナ
その 4つ 目の場合は それはラーガギナドーサギナモーハギナラーガモーハギナ
ジャーティジャラビヤーディソーカパリニワドッカドーマナスーパヤーシーディという風に燃えていると
それは項目 項目 項目に当ててあげて念じるんです
念じると心が悟り達します
時間的には早く終わりましたので
そこら辺で終了します
何か質問とかある方いらっしゃいましたら
この機会に えーと じゃあ奥の方の女性の方
すいません まず 2回戻っていただいてありがとうございます
あの 仏教の教えの中に愛別離苦っていうものがあると思うんですけど
それにすごいなんかタイタニックのようなものなのか
見てもよくわかんなくて
なんか憧れちゃって 妄想の中でひどい思いをして
心は苦しみ抜いて もうこれ以上耐えられないというくらいの苦しみを受けて
非常にひどく苦しいので
これ以上苦しめないから
これはどうしてこんなものに憧れてしまったんだろうという問題なんです
愛別離苦って何なんですか？はっきり言って
あんた言ってることでしょうね
だから本当にひどいんですね
愛別離苦で死ぬ人はいますからね
死ぬ人もいる 私死んじゃうかもしれません
本当に苦しくて  うん だからそちらにこの問題っていうのは
私たちは法則を犯してるんですね
なんでこの無常なものをね
自分にはのものにならないものをね
自分の愛した人は自分のものに絶対ならないんで
遠くへ行ってしまう時に
いつまでも思い出し憧れたりで心が苦しみ抜いて
ください  はい すいません
自分のものにならないものに愛を抱いたことは法則違反でしょ
だから長老みたくなりたいなって
どうしてそこで諦めきれるのかって
そのお坊さんたちはみんな素晴らしい考えだと思って
だからそれは自分のものにならないものに
母親私はと思っちゃえばいいでしょ
それがどうしても何かすごく執着してしまうものが心の中に残ってるんですよね
それは思い出でしょ  思い出
兄弟なのかもしれないとか思ったりとか
思い出も過去のことを思っちゃうと同じ気持ちが現れますから
それもまあこんな終わったことをまだ考えてる
このバカっていうふうに思っちゃう
なんで？なんでバカかとお前はと自分で言ってみてよ
普通に  本当にバカみたいですよね
はい ありがとう  みたいっていうところでしてください
そういう風に自分で言っちゃえば
自分のアホらしさに笑っちゃえば
繰り返してください あなたはちょっと感情的にまだまだ抑えられて思いながらね
そうやって自分に笑って笑っちゃえば
もう終わりますよ そんなものは
そんな簡単な問題ですか？ 本当に簡単ですよ
馬鹿らしく 簡単です アホらしく
簡単です だから問題は苦しい苦しいと泣いてるわりに
我々は苦しみを捨てちゃって安楽になりたくない
なんかもうちょっとやべえとか
例えば前 どこかのローラーコースターの話がどこで富士？富士ランド
よみうりランド よみうりランドのジェットコースター
あれは怖くないよ あなたいて怖くない
嘘言ったか 前は富士急ランドとかね
急ランドとか そちらのジェットコースターは怖い
私たちは乗せてくれないんです
あの 60以上はダメですね
そういうことで何言うかとかわからなくなっちゃった
ちょうど愛別軸の苦しみについて憧れたくないのに憧れてしまうというのはどうしたらいいんですか？ 憧れた
憧れたくないんですよ
だんだんみんなのタイタニックに憧れるようになんだか憧れちゃって
どうしてもこれを解決してほしい
だからそれはまだ納得していないね
私は言いたいのは この目さえも私の希望通りに動かない
私は今日この瞑想をやろうと思ったんだから
ちょっとトライバージョンで自分でも実践してみたんですよ
私は私の爪を見て この爪は自分勝手で私の希望にならない
この皮膚は自分勝手で私の希望にはならない
この肉体の細胞は自分勝手で私の希望にはならない
だったら外にあるものは私の希望になるわけないでしょ
まあ放っておけと ということで
自分自身全体に自分の希望にならないんだから
自分ではないし 自分の魂ではないと
これ これ自分自分と思ってるから私がいる
だったら花は綺麗であってほしい
私がいるからご飯が美味しくなってほしいというふうに希望するんですよ
ご飯は自分勝手にも美味しくならないし
例えばたとえ世間で美味しいというご飯でも
食べる時の細胞たちの勝手な反応によって美味しくなったりならなかったりするんですよ
一応詩人なんですよ 詩人
詩を 詩を書くんですよ
うん で 花はいい ただ咲いてちっとか
そういうような話よ  だから
本当の詩人っていうのは
世の中の中でそのまま言っちゃうんですよ
何もおしゃれもなく それは素晴らしい詩になるんですよ
すいません ちょうどありがとうございます
うん はい そういうことで
自分の胸に何にもならない
顔でさえ自分の目にならないんだから放っておきましょう
はい  勝手にしてください
ほっときにしましょう
というふうに 悟りの境地が安穏の境地が生まれてくる
はい 次の質問に行きます
えっと 他の方 もう一人方
じゃあはい  今の経典の中で燃えているっていうのがちょっとよくわからないので
もう少し説明してもらえるとありがたいんですけれども
自分のものにならないっていうのはそうかなって何回もお話聞いていて
そうかなと思うんですけれども
四季が燃えているって言っても
まだ触れる前の対象だと思うので
その時点でどうして貪欲でもうすでに燃えているのか
だって目があるから見たいでしょ
じゃあ目が勝手にあってもいいでしょ
でも使いたいんですね
まだものを見てないんです
見る前に目あるから目に何か触れてほしいと思っちゃうんです
耳があるから何か触れてほしいと思ってるんですね
だから目そのものも生き物
生き物だから貪瞋痴で燃えているんですね
なんで燃えているのかというと
それから苦しみが起きる
心だからなんですね だから全体は燃えていると思った方が解脱の気持ちが
怨理の気持ちが生まれる
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想する人も
最終的に怨理嫌悪の気持ちが生まれなくちゃいけない
これは我々あまり言わないのは
嫌悪と言った途端 俗世間のレベルで勘違いするんで
俗世間のレベルで何でも嫌悪感じちゃうと
それは病気ですよ これはもうすごいレベルが高いところの嫌悪なんですね
だからそこをすごく危険だから
単語の使い方ね あまりそれ言わない
だから瞑想で智慧が現れちゃうと
嫌悪っていうのは高度な智慧っていうことになりますね
離れたくなる すべて捨てたくなることもネガティブではなくて
極端なポジティブな態度になる
例えば 実際自分の家が燃えていると
家から逃げることはポジティブ的なことでしょ
だからそれだったら家がなんのことなくあるのに
作ったばっかしの 1年も経ってない家があるのに
家に戻りたくない ああ
嫌だって言っちゃった
あんたなんか変だよでしょって言うんですね
そうではなくて 家が本当に燃えている
だったら ああ 嫌だ 逃げましょうということは正しい態度なんですね
ですから ますヴィパッサナー瞑想で本当に燃えていることを眼耳鼻舌身が苦でしか何もないんだと認識するために苦しみが何もないんだと
吸ったりする 吸うことは苦しい
吐くことは苦しい 本当はやりたくないんだけど
やらなくちゃいけないから
そうするとなおさら苦しい
その時苦しみ感じるんですよ
集中力が生まれてくると
吐く時も苦しみを感じるんですよ
...そのことが苦しみだったらやめちゃえと
やめられないんですね
そうするとなおさら この苦しみを感じて嫌悪っていうことが生まれてくるんです
ああ いや これ何もないんだと
宝物は この現に非実質世界に燃えているっていうことは
そういうことで 普通のアーディタンといいますから
まあ普通の火にたとえてみてください
そんなにややこしく考える必要もないんです
前の質問した方に言ったように
えらい気持ちよく気楽に考えた方が解脱に達しやすいです
燃えているとか 普通に燃えていることと同じ
だから目は燃えているってことはあまりわからないのは
目にものが触れて感じて
その感情の方で燃えていると言ったってわかるんだけど
目は燃える なんかそこら辺なんですね
それはちょっとわからないとかね
まあまあ それもそれでいいですよ
それでわからないままでもいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
やっぱりそういうよりも
耳があるんだから使わないことにはならないね
やっぱり使いたいんです
みんな音楽聴いたり 次何聴く？とかね
探し求めちゃうんですね
だから燃えてるんです
目があるんだからって放っておけばいいのに
やっぱり見たいんでしょ
だから目が燃えてるんですね
見たくて 耳が聞きたくて
ベロが味わいたくて燃えているんです
あのベロにはそんなに力ないんだから
24時間味わいとかはないんです
ベロってすごく弱いんです
で でもそれなりに味わいたいんですね
例えばご飯食べて時間がちょっと経つと
お茶飲んだりする 別に水分は必要ってわけでもなくても
何かお茶飲んだりするとかね
それでまた時間経ってもう一回食べようということになったりして
なんで日本であれほどたくさんのお菓子やね
おせんべいのもう何万種類もあったりとかね
だから普通の店に行ったら
もう棚もうあるわあるわ
ただポテトチップスももう種類もっとあるみたいですね
塩味があって もうバーベキューの味があって
塩海苔の味があるわあるわ
もうだからもうただのポテトチップスで食っちゃったら脂肪が溜まって危ないなのに
なんであんな食うのかというと
口の味わいなんでしょ
ですから やっぱりベロは放っておけばいいのに
何か味わいたいんですね
だからベロはそのまま放っておいても
そいつはイライライライライラ燃えているんですよ
例えば私は瞑想をする場合は
はい それではみんな目を閉じます
閉じます 閉じます 閉じてください
言ったとたん みんなバチッとやめる
それから瞑想終わって
では3回目を開けます
開けます 開けます 開けてくださいったら
閉じてるんです だからまあ
そんなもんでもう笑って
こんなアホに悟るわけないと思ったりもしますけどね
やっぱり見たいんですよ
それはだいたい初心者指導で起こるんだから
私は何か変なことでもしたらどうしようかと
見たくてたまらない 見るものは何もないんだけどね
初心者の場合 そういうことで
耳があるとどうしても聞きたい聞きたいとイライライライラしているんですね
体そうでしょう 何かに触れたい
何かに触れたい あのローラーコースターで
あのこの専業さんに言ったように
登ると時間は大丈夫です
落ちる時ですよ 怖くなるのは
あれ 何なのか知ってる？その時瞬間ですけど
無重力感なんですよ あの無重力空間で体から感覚感じないんです
ほんのわずか  １ 秒もないんです
落ちる時間は  0.5秒ぐらいかな
それが私たちの長く時間
あー怖くなったと言いそうになるんです
あの無重力瞬間で体に感覚なくなっちゃったんです
だから体が燃えてるんですよ
何か触れよう 何か触れよう
なんで上がることは曲がったり曲がったり
曲がったり上がっても減っちゃうんですから
まあちょこちょこほとんど直線に上げてもらうんでしょ
その時でも重力を感じるんですよ
それで落ちたらやべえじゃなくて
あのベルトで締めてるんだから大丈夫やとかね
思って興奮ならない それで言ってごそごたんと落としちゃうと
みんなキャーとなるんです
あ 怖かったとか言っちゃっても
ほんの １ 秒以下 だから体も燃えてる
感覚欲しくて 感覚欲しくて
だから私は実験したことありますよ
言ってるのは本当に実験して
なんでローラーコースターみんなが怖いと言うのかと思って乗ってみたんですね
それで行って行って この落ちるんで
あ なるほど これか それだけ
もうこれ まあ無重力 まあ終わり
はい 次また感じる だからみんな面白くないくらいボンスじゃなと思ったでしょうね
だって全然びっくりもしない
感動しないんだから そこであのストレートフォーリングあるでしょ
あの棒を棒に 周りに椅子があって
そこを上げて 上げて 上げて
上げて 上げて上げて上げて上に行ってドカンと落としちゃうんです
あの落ちる瞬間でほんのわずかで落ちるのは
すごいスピンで あれで
あの あの油のね あれでもう止めるんですよ
あんなわずかな 1 分か 1
分じゃなくて  1 秒  2 秒のあれにね
まあお金払いたくない
今はね まあ研究終わったんだからね
無重力か これかねとか
でも何周か見るでしょ
宇宙飛行士たちが無重力で
それ怖いと驚いたらね
だから訓練する時はあんなローラーコースター状態じゃないんですよ
回して回して あらゆる方向に回されて回りまくっちゃって
この感覚をちょっと違う次元に持ってくるんですよ
だからあの人々は無重力空間っていうのはなんのことなく面白がっちゃうんで
何も感じないこと だから楽しいとは思いますよ
その方で言ったら はい
そういうことで体も燃えてる
体はもう何か触れたくて
触れたくて もういや もうずっと
しかし ややこしいことは体
体を感じるんですよ 例えばこの手を伸ばしてみると
手は手を感じるんですね
だからいつでも体燃えてないでしょと勘違いする
で 燃えてることはわからなくなっているのは
それに感じているからなんですね
そこで手を伸ばしてみると
手は感じるんだけど どんどん感覚が空に変わるんですね
空に変わって ああ 疲れて痛くなっちゃった
はい こうしましょうと言って
別な感覚にするんです
とにかく縁起に起因はそれに燃えているというブッダの言葉だから
まあどうにもならない
それはその通りなんです
はい  はい もう一方 手を挙げていらっしゃったと思いますけど
どうぞ前のほうの方 いかがですか
はい えーと 慈しみのフルバージョンの一番最後の行なんですが
すべての生命に苦しみを乗り越えることができますようにとあるんですが
あんまり聞いたことがない言葉なので
どこからどこにどこから来た言葉なのかなと思って
...仏教は  [笑い]仏教の考えでしょ
あんた大乗仏教の文化の中に生活してるでしょ
大乗の坊さんたちもそんなことを毎日のように願ってるでしょ
一切衆生の何でしたっけ？ 衆生無辺誓願度ですね
でしょ それは仏教の考えなんですね
だから経典にあるとかいう話じゃないんですよ
あまり経典はもっと理性的に喋るんだから
これは実現可能かというと
ちょっと無理ですね 一人一人が修行しなきゃ悟れませんよ
しかし 私の修行のために
私の心を無限に拡大するためにそう願うんです
それはあくまでも自分の修行なんです
私が全ての生命が解脱に達しますようにと思ったら
誰も解脱に達しませんね
現実的には でもそこまで屁理屈で持っていかないで
それは私の気持ちです
ということにするんです
私はそういう人間です
一切衆生が解脱に達してほしいという気持ちの人間ですと思っちゃうと
効き目が分かれますね
はい  方向はなんですか？上の方向
下の方向 突きまいの  それは次元を破るためにやってる一つの方便なんですね
具体的にどういうふうに
ただ上の方を想像しているんです
上の方を想像すると 頭の上の方でしょ
そこは無限に行くでしょ
宇宙までずっと  宇宙までもうリミットないね
はい ここは終点ってないんでしょ
だからまず一つの方向
そこで宇宙に行って リミットがない
もういたる生命が幸せでありますように
それなんとなく微妙に実感できたところで
はい 前の方向にも行くんですね
そこでどこでもリミットがなくなっちゃうと
まあなんか面白い経験になるんです
六方になってくると それは具体的な方向なんですね
方向には終点 中央点 セントラルポイントないんだから
自分をセントラルポイントポイントということにするんです
下というと地面から  そうそうそう
繰り返して  自分がいるところから下
地球を突き抜けて宇宙
そうそう 地球を突き抜けて
もう無限の空間までの宇宙空間まで行く
それでいいんですか？ うん
はい  はい それでは質疑応答の方はこのぐらいにして
カンティ パラマン タポ ティティンカ ニッバーナ パラマン ワダンティ ブッダ